[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
rich is back again with another podcast
good evening and hi and welcome to
Auntie Jenny's Village podcast it's your
boy The Fresh Prince of Zoom
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men now I'm
not saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you'd like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
then get out okay okay then then get out
then get out faster Esther then get out
I'm not here to get canceled today most
men want a woman that has some degree of
femininity where they feel like they're
taking care of taking care of I'm a lady
like I'm submissive and you'll be
surprised because I will say what I want
to say now and I'll say well I want to
say with my mind but my demeanor doesn't
change and I'm gonna look down on him
because at the end of the day whoever
you're with is a reflection of you what
has happened to society that has made
the normal man a waste man I would feel
so so bad asking a guy to buy like a
three thousand dollar bag
[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
you guys gotta make sure you clap all
right before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in and guys I just
realized it's been
um
over this time last year was when the
show was actually starting to pick up so
it's kind of exciting it was like June
last year we started to you know blow up
um but before we start don't forget like
the video on your way in that's the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these live streams okay and you
already know if you have watched two or
more of our lives and you don't
subscribe we have beef
um okay a couple announcements before we
start the show
um we are doing two panels this week
we're gonna do a panel tomorrow on
um I know we did one last week but we we
actually have a planned panel on body
positivity and then we have another
panel Friday what topic are we doing
Friday
is it the trans stuff yeah we're doing
the trans stuff I think on Friday
um also guys we have
um super chats today over what dollar
are we gonna read
20 okay so over 20 we are going to read
super chats today so if you guys have a
question for the panel Super Chat it I
will be checking the panel um during the
show also how many likes to open up the
chat today
okay a thousand likes and we'll open up
the chat today also guys um we have four
membership tiers you have to get the
first tier to be a part of the chat
until we open it up second tier you get
to see our behind the scenes Vlogs
Discord third tier you get to connect
with me on social media and a fourth
tier you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month I really recommend this if
you are trying to grow on YouTube you
know some would say I'm a YouTube genius
um I I would say I'm a YouTube genius so
you know sign up for that call if you
want help growing on YouTube also guys
follow my Instagram my first one got
banned it's just pearly things one
um we have wife school I'm actually I'm
doing an episode Saturday where I'm
gonna do um a dance instructor it's
gonna be fun so subscribe to wife school
to see that also guys
um we have one official pregame page on
Instagram
And subscribe to our talents channels
Auntie Jenny King Richie's uh and yeah
that's it so
um welcome to the show guys thank you so
much for coming
um to start we're gonna do name age
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself starting here and then go
around
so my name is Savannah Antonia I am 25
years old I am single for now and uh are
you looking
yeah a fun fact about me um I do tarot
readings very random what is a tarot
reading territory when people exactly
that when people get cards and they sort
of like read people's energies and stuff
through there oh I see yeah that kind of
scares me a little bit it is scary yeah
because I feel like it's like Spirit
stuff is it oh yeah it is yeah
[Music]
hello my name is yusra I'm 26 years old
um I am dating but it's a bit
complicated at the moment so I don't
really know and a fun fact there's like
one guy you like or what I'm nosy so I
like that I'm dating one guy but it's
been it's like on and off yeah he
doesn't know what he wants or you don't
know what you want it's both of the
sights it's been a bit tricky tricky
both ways okay for
um yeah and a fun fact about me actually
I'm I still think that I have a talent
that I haven't discovered yet so I'm
still looking forward to discover this
talent in myself
what what do you think it is I don't
know I'm still digging okay
I was like singing music no nothing no
no no but I'm but I'm sure that I still
have something okay okay
um The Fan Favorite the viral the
traditional woman welcome to the show
Welcome Back Nazarene thank you for
having me um my name's Nazareth and I'm
22 years old and what was the other
thing a fun fact yeah relationship
status I I'm single for now
um and a fun fact about me is I
I'm very passionate about the pandemic
being a scam and I try and spread truth
about loads of matters which are being
um hidden from the public so yeah and
she wants a guy that can kill a cow and
I want a guy that can kill a cowboy
okay I'm glad uh I'm MLD 37 single and
fun fact about me uh I've been going to
a lot of restaurants here in London and
I guess they keep forgetting to
seasoning the food so I carry a bottle
Tabasco with me now every time I go to a
restaurant you're not the biggest fan
that's why I cook so much more than I
eat out it's not everywhere it's bland
I'm sorry guys but I'm just I'm not the
biggest fan of the food here just carry
a bottle Tabasco with you I think we're
just so used to like the flavor
in our food I thought I thought fish and
chips would have like some seasoning in
the batter oh nice yeah even today when
I went to a steakhouse it was just like
the blandest steak like I was like no
salt pepper yeah and I said so I just
I drowned it into ASCO though the staff
was none of the British girls are even
arguing they're like yeah
it depends where you go personally if
you go to the small restaurants they're
quite good yeah okay yeah that is yeah
yeah
agree to disagree Team America Team
America USA USA go ahead go ahead my
name's Rosie I'm 20 years old and a fun
fact
I don't know do you have any hobbies do
you have a job
oh yeah take one okay are they teeth
whitening I'm a cosmetic teeth whitener
oh okay yeah cool how long I was
wondering can you tell if people have
had their teeth whitened is it easy for
you to tell
yeah yeah when people come to me I can
tell whether it's their first term or
they've done a few sessions but yeah
that's my hobby okay well guys welcome
to the show so um today you know we've
done a lot of shows this week on Andrew
Tate but there's been so many updates
um so to start I want to know do you
guys so actually sorry I'm gonna I'm
gonna start so Andrew Tate this week was
charged with grape and human trafficking
um so I want to start by saying do you
guys think he's guilty or innocent based
on the information you know
I don't think I've followed it closely
enough to give an accurate answer to
that
um but I feel like in some respects if
you know this has been under
investigation for quite a while he's
been under house arrest and stuff like
that I do feel like within that time
they probably haven't have had enough
time to compile a lot of evidence and
that to sort of prove him to be guilty
yeah it's like it's it's suspicious it's
taking this long right yeah right
exactly that's my take okay what's your
take actually I've been following the
case a bit uh closely lately but I I'm
not in a position to tell whether he is
guilty or not but just uh the um the I
mean the charges are a bit uh non non
non-understandable to me because they
said uh the he has been charged for
something related to tick tock accounts
and making uh money out of tick tocks so
this is really really uh funny for me so
even what is the revenue that would be
generated from a tick tock account
compared to other businesses so this is
a bit tricky yeah because initially
everyone thought it was from the cam
work yeah right so everyone thought that
was what they were accusing them of but
now it's coming forward that everything
they're accusing them of was in the last
like year or two yeah so and they're
saying they're forcing women to to pick
something and I know I know the payout
on Tick Tock it's you don't make [__]
and that's that's a bit tricky for me
okay like a government to to I mean to
charge someone with these kind of
um
um this charges basically okay go ahead
and answering I think what the majority
of the public are forgetting is it's
innocent until proven guilty so for me
at this point he is innocent because he
hasn't been proven guilty until they
have evidence which shows him doing it
it's concrete evidence which shows that
he definitely is doing human trafficking
and rape that's when I'll change my mind
and say okay yeah he's guilty but for
now he's innocent because if we're going
by the standard of the law it's innocent
until proven guilty and I think everyone
has to remember that otherwise it gets
very dangerous and it's definitely a
breach of Human Rights and
um it's a it's a danger to free speech
as well I think because if you can just
if if you don't like what someone's
saying and then someone else can go and
make an allegation against them and then
they get charged and imprisoned for
something they didn't even do and they
haven't been proved to do you know
anyone can get imprisoned for just
speaking about things that people don't
agree with so yeah innocent until proven
guilty all the way
uh It's tricky because
um
Romania is just notoriously corrupt
there's it's inevitable to to even come
to any other conclusion and he does have
a lot of money and when he sees the
money from these people it goes to the
politicians and the government and so
um you know he doesn't have the most uh
clean past as well because like he's
moved on you know the cam stuff you mean
like just the things he's been saying
like he said it when he was a smaller
content producer and so I guess that you
know he wasn't really planning for that
to be analyzed by hundreds of millions
of people right you know what I mean I
have a friend and um her and I pretty
close and she's a Romanian lawyer and
she was looking at the say this whole
case and she was telling me in her
personal opinion it wreaks corruption
and um you know she's working like in
the legal system for Romania and we
actually pulled up the documents because
this is all public information and the
uh Romanian judicial system so looking
at circumstances
um you know I I don't want to wish
jail time on to anybody who doesn't
deserve it and and Andrew Tate has been
cool to me
um so I just I mean my heart goes out
for these guys my heart really goes out
for these guys because they're in a bad
spot you know but I mean
he I mean it's just yeah it's just
really bad to be honest with you I wish
nothing but the best of these guys
because I mean when you live in a
country that is notoriously corrupt
right
there is a probability that that
corruption will be used against you kind
of like the whole censorship argument
right now people like censor sense or
sensor well inevitably that censorship
will be turned and used on you so I just
I hope and pray that these guys you know
are going to be okay because it's really
just terrible I would I would not wish
that on well maybe my worst enemy button
not my regular enemies
I haven't
um
been looking at the case to
briefly like I know the brief amount of
stuff to know
I've always kind of been a fan of Angie
Tate so personally
I don't believe it
but if it is true then my heart goes out
to the ladies the lady because I
wouldn't wish anything like that up on
anyone but personally I just feel like
they they let him off on Bell was it or
suspensions or whatever yeah
so they let in one house arrest and
I don't know like there isn't really
hardcore evidence is there and then
they're trying to get him back into jail
now I just feel like they're trying to
do anything because well in Romania like
the judicial system is pretty corrupt
you you have six months to incarcerate
someone and or put somebody on house
arrest while you collect evidence
against them in the United States I
think you can only do it for 21 days you
have 20. wow don't quote me on that but
I believe that is what I heard Myron
saying uh because he's a former federal
agent and I believe that the United
States government they have 21 days to
build a case against you and prosecute
you so in Romania now they have six
months so now they're gonna have to go
to trial and some people are saying this
trial is going to be one to two years
long so it's looking like the Tates are
going to be on house arrest for one to
two years wow that's crazy
it's crazy because it's like all off of
one girl's accusation one two girls
accusations American Woman
um so we're American woman who is
cheating on her boyfriend
oh really because yeah that that was the
first thing that triggered the whole
problem was that girl was in the Tate's
house and her boyfriend caught her and
then
she was like oh well I'm being held
against my will so the boyfriend called
like I don't know if I don't know if he
called Interpol or somebody called some
kind of National Organization you know
some kind of uh police organization and
then they went and then that was the
first round of trouble for the Tates
and so you know that's just I don't know
it's just terrible to just look at this
whole situation you know because I mean
that's why you don't [__] around with uh
people have girlfriends like you know
like if she's just she says she's taken
like just she's
if she's evil enough to betray her
boyfriend she's evil enough to betray
you you know there's bad news all around
yeah can I interject slightly there
wasn't one of the accusations also human
trafficking as well so was this the same
woman that has also said this or is this
other accounts from other people because
as I said not followed this it's a
couple things I think is it's is it just
three charges or is it also formed a
criminal organization wasn't it isn't it
uh grape yeah human trafficking human
trafficking money laundering and forming
a criminal organization so the criminal
organization I believe is just they're
saying that Andrew Tristan and then
their assistants these four people are
technically a criminal group right so
the thing is a lot of times when the
governments want you to be in trouble
they will
kind of like throw as many charges that
like can stick on paper like in state of
Florida if you get caught with marijuana
right and it's a plastic bag they'll
charge you for the marijuana charge and
then they'll also charge you for drug
paraphernalia and drug paraphernalia is
the plastic bag that the weed is in when
traditionally drug paraphernal is like a
crack pipe or heroin needle or something
like that it's his prosecutors they try
to get as many charges as possible on
people to kind of justify the spending
that they're getting from the government
be like look at us you know we're
locking people up so I mean who knows
these are the things they've been
officially charged with now they're
still going to go to trial and they
could win trial because they I heard
that they have a really from my Romanian
lawyer friend she was telling me that
they have a really good lawyer as well
so you know it's still going to go to to
trial and knowing the Tates you know
they're going to fight tooth and nail
those guys are not weak men at all
they're gonna fight tooth and nail so
we'll see what happens
so um he posted a video today
um I don't know if it was today or
yesterday but we're gonna play it if you
guys want to pull it up
um also I think there's a Super Chat I'm
gonna read
um
if sneaker or Nazarene if snika wasn't
gonna marry her I will you've been
you've a marriage request and then under
Mussolini the mafia was crushed so us
Western governments turn to what they're
becoming these activities are going to
be crushed as well
foreign
[Music]
okay you guys have it up or no
um okay we'll we'll wait a second then
um so while we're waiting for them what
impact do you think Tate has had on
young men
oh my God hello
hello I would say it overall positive I
mean I don't think these guys like yeah
I want to be like Andrew Tate time to
human traffic some hoes
they're like no I want to be rich I want
to be jacked and I I think you know
again like his past stuff when he talks
about some of the stuff that's you know
not necessarily the most uh favorable in
the current light that he's in right now
I think that his overall message to
young men is really beneficial because I
think there's a lot of directionless men
in the world right now and with these
directionless men I mean there's so much
uh just every agenda trying to push them
towards something that's not gonna be
beneficial to them because Society is
kind of in the west right now is kind of
having a lot of trouble because men are
not strong anymore men are not leaders
men don't even know how to lead well
they're told they're not allowed to lead
right I mean even even insinuating that
a man should lead a relationship is like
crazy nowadays like even even saying you
should listen listen to your man is
crazy or you belong to your man like I
think most people haven't even seen a
traditional relationship yeah I think
that's I think both sides too because I
think a lot of women too just have no
idea right how to like be decent in a
relationship you know it's both sides
it's a western phenomenon yeah well and
how are we supposed to know when most
you know most people if parents were
married they fought all the time
you have single mother homes we have an
epidemic of people that are in sexless
marriages we have an epidemic of people
that are fighting all the time and we
have an epidemic of women divorcing
their husbands so it's like how how are
people supposed to learn if they've
never seen it and also the school
systems have a massive impact impact on
relationships in general because
um even in my school I went to an ulgo
school and
um we would very much talk that if
you're if you're not a feminist you're a
bad person and you you know you're a bad
woman for not standing with other women
and believing that women believe all
women yeah no matter what believing that
they're like you know the epitome of
life
um so I actually had a teacher say an
assembly one day if you're not a
feminist you should be ashamed of
yourself yeah and that is like a message
which is so damaging because it
literally means you go into your life
um thinking that you are somehow
on the same level or above men in every
aspect when actually you're not and if
you go into a relationship with that
mindset you ruin it it just it doesn't
work and how many girls call themselves
a queen a 10 you don't see men doing
that and if they do they're ashamed
immediately yeah but all of this is
having a massive effect and then men are
being or boys in school are being told
not to um not to be aggressive not to
show their masculine side they're being
told to act like women
um because it's they're being told it's
more attractive to girls and actually
it's the opposite yeah and I learned
that the older I got and I thought that
I would find more feminine men
attractive like if they're a more
sensitive more calm gay yeah when
actually I didn't find that attractive
because when I came across it I was like
oh this is horrible yeah and then I just
I just want to like leave so this is the
thing you need you need a man who is
masculine who is strong and who stands
up for himself in every
um sense of the you know meaning of that
and he does that and he's shown men
young men especially to do that and I
think that is something which is so
commendable and so rare to come by and
he yeah I think he's made a massive
impact on a young man especially it's
irrefutable his impact I mean another
thing is this too you know just
objectively speaking he didn't like
knock on all these young men's doors and
like force them to watch him and follow
him you know there is a gigantic vacuum
this is why Jordan Peterson has become
popular this is why people like Jocko
willink right I mean there has been a
rise of masculine father-like leadership
type people Andrew Tate's like the kind
of the cooler edgier older brother and
so
um right now you're having this kind of
like you know digital masculine
Renaissance happening and it's not
because you know guys are bored or
whatever it's like they are looking for
this they're looking for guidance and
then you know I saw the writing on the
wall in 2012 that's why I left America I
was like this thing is going south yeah
and
um you know traditionally too in like
Asia you know they're still adhere to
the traditional values and you know
there's not like school shootings in
Asia you know there's not like wild
crazy stuff happening like that it's a
very peaceful harmonious existence over
there and you know I think Joe Rogan
said it Wes like he says we have a
mental health crisis in America
disguised as a gun crisis yeah and
there's just so many people that are
unwell and the backbone of being a
well-balanced individual is coming from
a stable household do you know what made
me realize how unwell people are so like
getting on social media because it would
be so weird it would be like girls that
like I don't even know that well would
get so mad at me over something I didn't
say to them do you know what I mean so
and I'm just like you have to be crazy
to be this angry like I love girls like
that I was friends with before or new
and they'll just like walk past because
they're so mad like they're like I had
one girl threatened to fight one of my
friends for being friends and I was like
what what household did you grow up in
to like like to be this crazy single
mother most likely I don't know I don't
know but but it's like it kind of opened
my eyes where I'm like people really
didn't grow up in like a sound
two-parent environments and there's
lasting effects that happen for
Generations because it's like if the
women and the men aren't learning how to
be husbands and wives like what is that
what are they going to teach their kids
yeah
yeah it's broken it's broken families
it's broken families and broken people
raising broken people and it's like kind
of like you know it's cascading because
the number of single mother households
is not going down it's going on it's
going up yeah it's an endless cycle
actually I think that might have been
emasculated for a very long time
and Andrew came here to spread a message
that a Young Man worth thriving to hear
that masculinity matters that
masculinity because they all have that
drive inside of them but it has been uh
shut up and they didn't know how to
express it but Andrew came and tried to
awaken this in their uh in their minds
so I think his message is extremely
positive he didn't he does not teach
something bad if you look at the core of
the message itself it's uh basically
just learning good habits and investing
on the oneself and the mindset and
taking good action uh in the world and
this is a good message to humanity and I
don't see like a point why would people
argue you know you know what I think
gets these guys in trouble like the
super masculine ones it's like locker
room talk it's like because most women
have never heard the way guys talk like
amongst themselves it's you know like I
don't know if you've ever been in like a
room full of guys and you're like oh my
God why do you talk like that and so
it's like these guys like Trump like
taking like all the super masculine you
know toxically masculine guys will get
in trouble when locker room talk gets
leaked basically yeah which I especially
when in early like when you're early in
the manosphere it's basically locker
room talk because it's all guys you know
yeah and this is the thing I I've come
across so many guys who are like yeah
but haven't you heard what he said like
he's so disrespectful towards women and
I'm like I know for a fact that when
you're alone with your friends you say
things which if they were leaked and if
you were a public figure yes that would
get you in so much trouble people would
completely be turned against you the
media would twist things and I know for
a fact you've said things in private to
your friends that you would never want
to be leaked out so just put yourself in
that situation it's just happened to him
and it's you know the people who act
like they're the most self-righteous say
like the worst [__] and they got the
worst like skeletons in their closet
yeah you know when you have somebody
who's just like pushing whatever agenda
like you know I I don't know if I should
say his name but like you know all these
big facing names and uh it's just so
funny how they get all self-righteous
because I it's the same thing like when
you see the stuff in the manuscript and
the red pill creators like some of these
guys like you know my my girl always
submits to me and like we never have
problems and like every time we have
sexy orgasms it's like no that's not
true because that's just not true
anybody trying to put on this facade of
perfection
morally you know physically relationship
wise whatever that's a thousand percent
[__] because we are all flawed
people nobody's perfect you know I think
the number one thing that matters is you
just strive to do better but well and
the one thing that irritates me is they
just especially like from the
conservative side they'll crucify him
for the cam work stuff yeah and I'm just
like and I'm just like he's not perfect
like he's religious now but he wasn't
always so you can't judge them by the
same I mean you you can judge them and
disagree with it but it doesn't mean
they belong in prison yeah but the thing
is do these same men not watch porn
yeah yeah I can guarantee you that
they're the ones who watch porn secretly
so yeah it's just the whole thing is so
hypocritical and just pathetic to listen
to
um I'm not gonna lie he made a ladies
money too he made himself money so I
don't really understand what the issue
is yeah like everyone yeah um someone
says it's men's mental health month
Kings uh King do the video ready okay
foreign
so I just wanted to have an informal
conversation I was going to put a suit
on and do this formally but I think it's
better if I do this informally
highlighting some of the things that
everybody already knows about how the
Matrix operates and what they're trying
to do to me and what I believe is going
to happen next
it's quite interesting
that
they are attacking me and attempting to
vilify me at the exact same time
whereas real Predators which work for
the media establishment are being ousted
so it's really interesting to do a
juxtaposition and do a comparison right
between how they will treat Phillip
Schofield
who is confirmed as a groomer who is
admitting he has committed sexual crimes
and how they'll treat me a man with no
convictions and no admission of sexual
crimes
look at the differences in the headlines
look at how soft they are in their
interviews with him you've had quite a
week how are you
look at how now after only two or three
days the headlines are saying we should
forgive him
and feel sorry for him and let him off
whereas me who's been under constant
media assault for over a year
they never let up they never change
someone sent me a clip yesterday Phillip
Schofield saying he's going to kill
himself and how sad he is last week
if my
Waters hadn't been there
[Music]
I wouldn't be here why do they keep
pushing me why do they keep pushing me
playing the sympathy card and all the
headlines are now like yeah we can't
keep attacking this poor man for one
year they attacked me and they will not
stop
and this highlights the difference
between the people who are on the side
of the establishment and the people who
are not on the side of the establishment
I've been offered to sell my soul very
many times
I want everyone at home to understand
you do not become the most Googled man
on Earth
especially amongst the demographic of
young men which have money to spend
without very large companies and
corporations becoming extremely
interested in you
I've been offered 50 to 60 million
dollars my companies I'm not gonna name
all I had to do was shut up shut up take
the money wear the stupid hat
wave around the stupid drink whatever it
is and continue
to agree with whatever the Matrix says
regardless of my own personal feelings
my personal views and beliefs and just
push it on the minds of young children
and I refuse to do that I refuse to sell
my soul
if I would have sold my soul to a large
corporation
and then this attack happened which I
very much doubt this level of Matrix
attack would have even happened to me
but if it did then this large
corporation would speak to the media and
the media would be treating me like they
treat Phillip Schofield
they wouldn't be treating me with an
enemy they would treat me as an ally all
I had to do was sell my soul and I
refused
the recent BBC interview that took place
I don't think most people understand
genuinely how snaky
that interview was the reason
I had to destroy her so ruthlessly
because of how the interview was set up
when I was in jail the BBC was
constantly trying to get me to get an
interview or the phone that I refused
when I left Jay the BDC begged me
begged me for an interview daily begging
me and for three months I refused
eventually once I understood after my
third month of house arrested
what the remaining government is going
to do to me which we're going to discuss
shortly I thought now would be a good
time to get an interview
BBC begged me saying that Romania has
one of the most corrupt Justice systems
in Europe that there's serious problems
with the case lots of evidence has been
leaked shows Anders innocent that Andrew
thought the story hasn't been heard that
we're interested in Fair and unbiased
journalism that we don't want to come
there and do a hit piece we want to
speak to him and try and find out the
truth of what's happening in fact we're
going to send you the questions we want
to ask in advance I'm not a coward I
never ask the questions in advance I
don't care because I'm a professional
and I will destroy anyone instantly but
they sent us a list of questions
which was sent shown to me I was like
well those are actually interesting
questions what's my mental health like
what's remaining in jail like what's it
like being in a courtroom where
everyone's speaking the language you
don't understand and having your Liberty
deprived of you I thought this is going
to be an interesting interview I agree
the BBC all my smiles and all lies sent
us this entire
spiel
turned off turned the cameras on
sat down and attacked me have you ever
um put any an applied in his
psychological control or anything
and I respect women this idea that a man
that I'm so much smarter that I can
hypnotize somebody I think it's
extremely misogynistic idea I think your
idea is misogynistic to believe that
women don't have their own free thoughts
and free Minds
they attempted to sucker punch me they
attempted to shake my hand and knock me
out with a sucker punch once the cameras
were on to hit me when I was off guard
they expected me to be off guard ready
to talk about my mental health
and hit me with these questions and me
make a fool of myself unaware of I am a
master of Aikido and when you attempt to
Sucker Punch me it simply misses and I
destroy you I think we're done
unmatched perspicacity
just because I'm the best there's ever
been
and me with my quick thinking
and nearly
incomparable wit can sit
and destroy a professional reporter and
her entire research team's preparation
just because I make that look easy
doesn't mean I should be forced to
succumb to these unfortunate
circumstances 99 of the population if
they were tripped the way I was tricked
would look a fool on camera they were
very prepared to try and make a fool of
me but I'm the best there's ever been
Schofield
where was the BBC's outright
outbreak when Rolfe
Paris where Jimmy Savile
they don't care where's the BBC's
outrage when certain other people high
level in Society members of the royal
family are caught having pictures with
minors they don't care but they will
continue to try and convince you that I
am something I am not on repeat over and
over and over again
these people are worse than disingenuous
they are worse than simply Liars they
are evil they are a club and if you sell
your soul and join the club they offer
you protection and if you don't they aim
to destroy you
which is what they're trying to do to me
the reason I decided to give the
interview to the BBC is because I now
believe that the next step
and I'm going to call it because I've
called everything that's happened to me
so far look at my old interviews I said
stage two they're gonna try and put me
in jail I understand that you get three
strikes in this game
strike one is they try and shut you up
and discredit you which I've just been
through strike two is they try and put
you in jail for no reason and strike
threes they kill you the truth is this
so I I knew it was coming I absolutely
Nutley knew it was coming because of how
orchestrated it was the only thing I'll
State this at the beginning the only
reason I'm upset by being canceled is
because I've expired one of my lives I
mean I've never killed myself don't
[__] try but bro because that's
what's next that's what's next it's
scary I'm telling you everyone thinks
I'm paranoid everyone thinks I'm crazy
every single organization on the face of
the planet's corrupt this is why I say
to people I say listen and I'm going to
say this on this podcast now to say on
every other one I would never ever kill
myself I truly believe they're going to
come and they're going to try and kill
me on a long enough time frame because
they tried to shut me up and I won't
shut up they're gonna try and put me in
jail they're gonna kill me and I would
never kill myself under any
circumstances ever and the reason I say
this and I say these people and they go
but what can they put you in jail for
and I'm like how ignorant are you in
your ignorance to believe they need a
reason you believe it's fair you believe
I can get a lawyer and prove myself
innocent that's not how it works they
decide you're guilty long before and
they find a reason why and it doesn't
matter what you do about it you will pay
the [__] price it's not fair none of
it is every single system is corrupt it
actually annoys me when people say it to
me well just get along why they can't
put you in jail if you're innocent yes
they [__] can and that's what people
don't understand about the world they
can and they do and they [__] will
and that's what's scary I'm gonna call
what's gonna happen next
The Matrix is extremely angry and they
are angry because their weapons aren't
working I remain unfazed this is the
first time in history someone who's
canceled became more popular than before
this is the first time in history where
a full broad side of media lies for over
a year across every single outlet that
they control has failed nobody believes
them number
so now what do they do well I believe
the UK is going to try and raise charges
against me don't know what for I've done
nothing wrong something's going to
appear from nowhere in fact I will say
that I have some very high level friends
and some whistleblowers who are
confirming exactly that to me they've
looked at me and thought we had to get
this guy what's he done nothing find
something fine who cares get some papers
move some papers around get a judge will
stamp them and put them in jail
it doesn't matter that I've done nothing
wrong
wrong I also want to say that I believe
the Romanian government is going to
charge me they're not going to charge me
because they have any evidence I'm not
going to charge me because I'm guilty of
anything they're going to charge me
because after a 14-month investigation
six months of arrest which is the
maximum they can possibly give me
without charge I don't think they can
just drop this
imagine they just dropped this tomorrow
oh we made it all up
imagine that
what choice do they have but to charge
me if they charge me I have to go to
trial now of course I still believe in
Romanian Justice I really truly believe
that in even with Romanian Justice
systems or Matrix control Justice
systems I'll be found innocent because I
know the case File I know what's in it
but that's going to take years they're
going to waste one and a half to two
years of my life make me go to trial
then when I'm found not guilty it's been
years who cares right
distance from event if they drop it now
it's the biggest story in the world they
can't drop it they're gonna charge me
they're not going to charge me because
I've done anything wrong they're going
to charge me because that's how the
Matrix works
unfortunately I'm up against an enemy
which I can't really truly beat
I can't beat them all I can do is
continue to discredit them to the point
where nobody believes them anymore
and I cannot do that without having
perspicacious intelligent people at home
who are analyzing the situation and
truly understand what is happening to me
if I have to March or myself if I have
to some degree sacrifice my Liberty
and the quality of my life to highlight
how the Matrix operates how the legal
system and the media work hand in hand
to try and convince the populace
somebody is guilty before a judge says
they are guilty because they have
pre-decided to say this person is guilty
because of his wrong thing
if I have to sacrifice myself to do
those things
then I guess at least my imprisonment is
a noble one
and I'm a man
and although Romanian jail is as close
to hell as you can find on planet Earth
if I have to suffer it I will do that
because I will not sell my soul
the point of this video is only to
highlight
and make clear the differences and how
the people inside of the club are
treated against versus the people who
are outside of the club and also for me
to predict the future for everyone to
understand when new charges come
when new countries attempt to attack me
when the Matrix unrelentingly continues
to print lies about me and tried to
convince the world that I am a bad
person I hope it does nothing else but
show the world that I am a good person
these people are liars the people they
tell you are good are not good the
people they tell you are bad are the
good ones do not believe a word that
they say
[Music]
all in all
my predictions to the Future are not
certain
my future is certainly not certain
whether I'll continue to breathe or
continue to be free nobody knows but the
one thing I can guarantee to absolutely
everybody at home and anybody who
believes in me in my message and anybody
who listens to me speak I will never
sell my soul I will never be controlled
and I will never lie
foreign
first question do you guys think the
Matrix that he's talking about is real
yes for sure yes there's no doubt do you
are you're a little I feel like you're a
little skeptical do you know what it is
what do your tarot cards say
I mean
I mean follow the stuff like it sounds
crazy right no it doesn't because it's
not that I don't follow this stuff I am
so with it when it comes to conspiracy
theories and really reading deeply into
this oh really hearing about the Matrix
and that you know this is all a
simulation all of this this isn't new to
me
um I I'm just really taking in that
video because that was what like 10
minutes long and I literally feel like
I've just sat through like MK Ultra or
something like what am I actually
listening to there's a lot going on
there definitely believe that the Matrix
as well we see a lot of loopholes in
this we see a lot of synchronicities and
things that make us question it my sort
of little bits that I find questionable
about it are things that he's trying to
like compare himself to Phillip
Schofield don't really think we can
compare the two Phillip Schofield was
seen for years as like a National
Treasure which is why everybody is like
so shocked that all of this has come out
who is Andrew Schofield sorry he's a
he's a correspondent on like a famous TV
show called this morning that we have on
we have one like Piers Morgan yeah yeah
but not as outspoken and controversial
it was very like light-hearted so he's
got his sort of co-host and they make
jokes and so what happened was he caught
doing anything so what essentially
happened was it came out that he was
grooming a young a young boy essentially
no
um so he had like this sort of like
Academy to help young people get into
media which is what he was doing I think
the kid was about maybe 14. someone can
correct me if I'm wrong
um and he was basically like yeah I can
give you like one-to-one like coaching
whatever and it's sort of like it's all
come out now the guy has like
obviously he's a lot older now he's made
like a video explaining you know this is
Phillip Schofield this is the guy this
is what's going on and that's it so
that's where the Scandal has come from I
don't really think you can compare
yourself to someone like that is he
openly gay that was the Scandal he's
been married for years and came out as
gay about a year or two okay I think his
point though is the interview do you
know what I mean because like they're
showing pity towards him but that's
that's where my point is also deriving
from it's that the nation essentially
has been very shocked about hearing this
news because this was seen as like I
said a National Treasure right but then
shouldn't do Tate has not had the
cleanest tracker but I would think like
it then it would be like a worse
interview because he's like everyone's
been bamboozled
yeah coming from a piece of shock right
it's not shocked you're not you know
you've got to have one or two reactions
when you're shocked you're gonna be
super angry you're gonna be like oh like
oh my God right the media are spinning
it like that for a reason
um I don't know if I don't think about
public to react think they're trying to
spin it in such a way that he's innocent
though if you look actually out there
and see the things that people are
saying people are literally disgusted by
this this man is literally said he was
going to take his own life if the media
really spinning it that he's innocent
his life if he's doing that [__]
and by the way I'm not I hate I only
wants to take his own life now because
he's a big fan because then you always
come out because you don't wanna like
kill yourself when you was grooming a
little boy and then now agreed did you
get it just drop them off somewhere in
White Castle
I mean I think I think the point is more
like he he committed a crime they know
he committed a crime and they're
treating him nicely is he not we're in
charge is he not going to jail why he
admitted it so he's not knows no charges
nothing against this guy know what's
going on as if as of now but not
innocent is the statute of limitations
over like the you know this is this is
the difference so one of them Phillips
Schofield
actually has been proven to have groomed
and had sex with him boy Andrew takes
two allegations yet look at the
difference in the media big difference
yeah one side is oh this guy explains
obviously the difference is because of
Andrew takes track record it's not the
same as Philip schofields and that's why
the reaction is different yeah
being very controversial that's why the
media are immediately taking this stance
I'm not saying it's okay that is why but
why does it why does it matter how long
they've known him if he's committed a
crime it's not about known that's that's
not my point the point was was that he
has been seen as a National Treasure so
that's the difference
has had a conjure he's got a
controversial track record so that's
where one of your own like you know what
I mean either we're innocent or guilty
by the way I'm just giving you an
explanation yeah so the media's job is
not to have sympathy for the people no
they're meant to be objective exactly
but they're not it makes me more a shock
to know that someone who is perceived as
a national Treasurer commits such a
thing yeah
towards someone like that at the
opposite I would be shocked and I would
put him like in the mainstream media as
well
that would be like Mr Rogers doing
something of the equivalent you know I
don't I have not seen a single person
since this has come out say I feel so
sorry for Phillip Schofield and if you
have I'd really love to see who that is
I mean he was right
in that video too in that video too he
was really laying and I was like oh I
wanted to take my life do it
[__] we don't need people like
you if you're out here doing that to
young children that's sick in every
sense of the word you've got children
and a family even if you don't even if
you have children and family I don't
give a [__] if you're single I don't
care what you identify as if you do that
[__] it's [__] disgusting do you
think it's a lack of Sympathy For Men
because it was a young man that was
sexually assaulted but if it was a young
woman like if Tate was oh imagine if
Tate was grooming a 14 year old chick
yeah or this guy or this film Schofield
guy yeah I would say this same thing you
know I think you know if it was a young
girl then everybody would be you know
see genuinely believe that that because
it was it happened to a young boy that
people don't feel any pity yeah you
genuinely believe that yeah I would say
I would say I think I I mean a lot of
pity just because I know it's a person
that's been assaulted I mean I just I
just think the reaction in the media
isn't the same like I mean there are
cases in the United States where
um a teacher groomed a kid and they put
the the young guy on child support yeah
that happens I mean you see the
differences in the sentences these
teachers will get like six months and
right now like you know as much as they
say about misogyny stuff like I think
right now missandry which a lot of
people don't even know what that means
but missandry's like the hatred of men I
think missandry is at an all-time high I
don't think women have hated men as much
as they ever have right now in human
history as they have right now but but I
don't necessarily want to say like you
know if it was a girl whatever don't
even imagine these kind of six scenarios
but I definitely want to say that the
situation with Andrew Tate and this
Phyllis Schofield guy it's not equal
thank you that's my biggest thing and
and it's not equal in what they did and
I think what this Phillips Schofield do
I did was way worse because it involved
an actual child that's disgusting in
every sense of the world I'll go on the
record say it's [__] disgusting yeah
and then the demonization of Andrew is
really you know it's it's it's a low
hanging fruit right now for everybody
like because it's just easy to say oh
look at this big strong guy with tattoos
like he's a bad guy doing this and you
know we don't know if he's innocent or
guilty yet we have to wait for the court
situation to handle itself but I just
think that there is definitely a
disparity in it but at the same time
though I will add this right Phillip
Schofield didn't become the number one
most Googled man on the planet Andrew
Tate did so then you know when you're
when you're bossing it up to like when
you like Pearl you could probably know
like when I started doing really well
with my business and when you started
doing really with your business I don't
know where people didn't even know
exists started coming out of nowhere
like [__] this person you know what I
mean they'll be like I talked to her
three years ago and I was traumatized
God damn
you know so there's a lot more hate on
tape because there's a lot more eyes on
him too you know and I wanted so I
wanted to say this too man big big UPS
to tape for the Showmanship for like
that was a great video yeah and like the
fact that the entire world is like
literally demonizing this man without a
concrete verdict from the judge saying
like you are guilty
um and I just want to go on record and
say like I really just hope he's not
guilty and I just hope that he can just
get out of the situation because it's
not cool to see somebody suffer like
this if they're innocent you know and he
keeps on saying he's innocent it's just
not a good thing do you think the media
would treat him different the Tate
different if he came out as a guy
okay we'll come back to this in about a
year's time and we'll see where Philip
Schofield is because I'm telling you now
this guy is not getting away with that
easily there's no way he's gonna be
allowed to just walk about it but that's
not the but the point is but the point
is it like that's not the point the
point is he was treated nicely even
trafficking alleged human trafficking
these guys
alleged is the key word but the point of
the matter is is that these are the
accusations so I don't know
that's not the point the point is one
was treated nicely and one wasn't I've
done it and so the point is nicely I
mean if you saw if you saw that that's
an interview yeah the interview
no but the the point is the interview so
I mean you saw the differences
look at all of the things they've been
saying on the internet about Philip
Schofield if you've actually read it
but the point is they're both mainstream
media so his point isn't that like I'm
sure they're both gonna get trolls I'm
sure they're both going to get Negative
criticism
isn't Philip guaranteed guilty
even Jesus Christ himself said have you
heard of children a millstone should be
tied to your neck you should be thrown
in a lake [__] that guy I don't have any
pity for that guy I'll punch him in the
face if I see him if that's okay with
London's law
[Laughter]
you've been for the past week you've had
a tough week what kind of toughness that
is mad I mean he did something very very
wrong in the eyes of everyone but
whereas where someone is only not even
charged you tell him you have this and
this you've been and you are the most
evil man on Earth do you think they're
doing that for for him asking him how he
is for him or do you think they're doing
it for the viewers well you know what it
probably is so let me ask you this is he
was he part of the BBC yeah he was part
of like no actually this morning's part
of ITV so yeah but I think at one point
he was part of the BBC he was on a
different show because they they may be
getting a Morning Show so if he's part
of the media organization they might be
going soft on him because then people
are like I think this is all like
orchestrated so we think that well
please yeah it's all like well that's
the that's the point of we're saying
it's a matrix that like that I mean
that's the point that all the people in
mainstream media are like connected yeah
and so on the mainstream media comes
because it'll look like they're like
they're just gonna look at the company's
bad you know what I mean so they're like
oh yeah our one employee was doing this
[__] but like and it's very different
walking into an interview where like
someone's gonna hear you out versus like
this happened to me once where like I
went on this interview and they're like
oh we're just gonna ask you about your
life I know
bad clip you've ever done every bad
thing you've ever said and I was like I
thought this was a nice conversation
that's the satellite on the BBC yeah
yeah I have a personal experience with
them
um I went on a documentary called on
injected I'm gonna say for the purpose
of this
um
and they spun it in a way where they
said okay we're going to give you an
opportunity to share with the world and
with the UK public why are you why you
chose not to take the injection
um for the pandemic that happened in the
past three years and it was spun in a
way to make it sound like it was a
positive thing that we had a chance to
share our views and everything I
obviously knew it was going to be a
setup and I went into that prepared for
that
um I had I'm not I don't think I can say
this but I was um I I had my own version
of events basically and they don't know
this and I
was based everything we said was spun it
was completely edited in a way to not
with that was disingenuous to how we are
as people
um the actual edit was completely
different to what actually happened in
the house
um they filmed us for five days to
really Tire us out and then only like
one hour went out so it was like they
they waited till we were so tired that
we said something which we didn't really
mean or that you know we could have
probably said better and they only put
those bits in so they are completely
evil and I know that evil they knew what
they were doing there were people in
there who weren't even who didn't even
have the thing themselves and then they
were still trying to spin it because
it's all for money let's be honest
because I was gonna say you know that
just happened to me too like there was a
gigantic viral campaign put against me
and it was all lies and manipulation for
money because these people like what
he's saying is legit people need to wake
up and realize like there are
legitimately evil humans out there like
in in the word evil is what I'm using to
describe them because it's true there
are evil people out there and the thing
is like you know the thing about this
nice cast we have here is we all get
along so No One's Gonna argue so sorry
but the thing is like you know I besides
everybody up here we're all decently
good people right but when you're a good
person the problem is you project your
goodness on other people
and you have to be vigilant and these
other people who are running these
organizations they're not good and
they'll come in and be Sly and be like
oh hey no we really care about you we
want to hear your side we're going to
have like a you know non-confrontational
friendly conversation blah blah blah but
there's an agenda because these people
are evil they don't want to play by the
rules there is an evil out there and
good people need to wake up and identify
evil and you know snuff it out because
that's what that's what we're having
right and they don't want truth like
they don't care about what's the truth
spinning and narrative yes and I think
like it's so funny because what they'll
do now is they'll pull up old tweets
where you've like changed your opinion
or old like post whatever it was but
it's like the side of someone that
actually wants the truth is that they
change their opinion on over time where
it's like the left just like they they
just have their narrative they have
their beliefs and they will not change
it yeah I think a lot of the things that
we're speaking about right now is just
the media as a holiday I don't think
this is just strictly and exclusively
the BBC I think this is the media as a
whole I studied and I have a degree in
journalism funnily enough and one of the
things you learn about is Media framing
so it's pretty much what we're talking
about now where you take these little
clips and then you sort of spin it to
frame a different narrative that is just
media I don't think that is just
exclusively the BBC when you think about
journalism this all first started and it
was all born out of Truth people wanted
to deliver the truth to people and
actually you know serve people what they
weren't naturally getting and this has
changed now because there's a lot of
money being pumped into these industries
and people just think well what's going
to sell so that's where that media
framing comes from but to sit there and
say it's just the BBC I think we need to
sort of broaden our Horizons a little
bit and saying it I'm saying it's just
BBC but we were talking about the BBC so
that's where that's why are you
defending the BBC Savannah no I'm I'm
just saying like blanket truth this is
just medium we need to sort of open our
eyes out to the fact that it's all just
no for sure for sure that's what I'm
saying yeah that's what I was saying
when I was talking about Phillip
Schofield versus Andrew Shake I'm
American yeah I'm American I don't know
where the [__] Philip Schofield is you
know but the world I mean we have a
woman you know from multiple uh
ethnicities here and she's from Morocco
you know you guys from the UK were from
America we all know who Andrew Tate is
Phillip Schofield is who the [__] is
that guy you know so that that's why we
were using the context of the BBC
because they've also recently tried to
bamboozle Tate as well with the recent
interview they're like oh yeah we're
gonna do this great interview that's the
only reason but you know what you're
saying about the media in general
thousand percent true like if you see
how these White House Press journalists
act they're animals absolute [__]
rabid animals and there are certain
things that they're literally all in it
together about have you seen the videos
of um the start of the
story they're talking about and every
single news
um Source or Outlet says things in the
exact same way with the exact same
wording as if it's a script even if
they're different political
um stances like it's the same thing so
they're literally all in it together
yeah have you seen that for all like the
like they're all the Morning News can we
pull it up is it let me what's it called
I'll I'll look it up it won't get me
banned off for YouTube no no no no no no
no no you got to be careful with
Nazareth
so careful I know I know I know I just
never know I'm gonna send it to an
iMessage because an iMessage yeah okay
so what is it it's basically all these
different commentators saying the same
thing there's all these news channels
yeah but don't you think that all goes
back to like the Matrix yeah absolutely
yeah yeah because don't you think all
the majority of the elite people little
pedophiles
cancel yeah no cancel
because don't you think covered only
come I believe I truly believe that
kovid pandemic yeah the pandemic
sorry guys
um pandemic was put into place when
at that time I remember
um
I don't want a name before we're in
trouble or something and we're already
in trouble
but like Obama you know like the Ellen
show it was it was a few people from
America I think Beyonce Jay-Z and stuff
like that they was fly they was flying
in and out onto an island it was like an
island yeah yeah
he went there
she she went to that Island as well and
she was with all the kids
there was a leaked list and she was on
it oh was she on the list but she has
partying with the kids is what you're
telling me yeah that was all naked
children there was literally videos on
Twitter these babies
and the island exists yeah yeah like the
island is literally apparently like
children kidnapped from like Mexico and
Etc I'm not so fine go on to Twitter and
write in um Pizza gate oh yeah I've I've
seen all that yeah
and that's when the pandemic got put
into place okay oh my gosh I got so deep
into pizzagate and insane no but then
they banned it yeah
even on Twitter you can't even you know
it's crazy even if you say anything
about Tate or he posts their voices or
whatever they program the algorithm and
the AI on Tick Tock to like instaban you
if you do that I remember I was in I was
little video um of Obama and me
see them yeah and it got taken down you
literally can't you can't find these
things on Twitter no more it's all been
taken down and then obviously the
pandemic come into place and in every
all the people that didn't really know
about that situation everybody was just
so worried about what was going on it
was just a big distraction King I sent
you the video on um as I texted it to
you yeah the video is crazy it's
actually crazy it blows your mind is it
five years ago too why not five years
when I first started to hear about the
Matrix stuff I was like whatever they
just need to push the X-Files buttons
I was like the more stuff happened I'm
like wait
I think there's a global Consciousness
raising too because absolutely I don't
know yeah you think so because you know
I'm also you know when in doubt bet on
dumb people so I don't know if like
what's gonna happen but I would say a
lot of people when they were forced to
take the injection two times like yeah
two Jabs you're you're good to go you
can take off your mask and like oh wait
now we got the Omicron now we got the
Delta now we got the [__] Lambda you
know and then our Lord and savior
Vladimir Putin comes and starts a war
and kovitz cured
where's the Nobel Peace Prize for Putin
yeah he he cleared he could covet from
all this video they're gonna bring up
okay
hi I'm Fox San Antonio's Jessica Headley
and I'm Ryan Wolfe our greatest
responsibility is to serve our Treasure
Valley communities the El Paso Las
Cruces communities Eastern Iowa
communities Mid Michigan communities we
are extremely proud of the quality
balanced journalism that cbs4 news
produces but
one side
explaining the country like in our
country the sharing of biased and false
news has become all too common on social
media War alarming some media Outlets
publish these same fake stories without
checking facts first the sharing of
biased false news
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy this is
extremely dangerous to our democracy
this is extremely dangerous to our
democracy this is extremely dangerous to
our democracy this is extremely
dangerous to our democracy
do you think it's the same people behind
the scenes just sending them the same
script yes I wonder if the people that
are reading it no do you think I don't
think they do no because I think they do
they're just I think you're
underestimating how shitty people are oh
I don't know I don't know people in
um like media history media but there is
one kind of mainstream media that I'm
familiar with I know people who present
shows on there and they I I they do not
I I don't believe that they know
basically I they're friends of mine so
maybe like it's even it's probably the
same people with Fox and CNN you know
what I mean like it probably so it's
like you feel like you're going to
different sources but it's the same
thing this is why I would say to people
do not watch the news go to the go to
other sources to find the news and look
at both sides and then make up your own
mind on things because you cannot trust
the news that's an example of like they
are all different spectrums of political
stances and they all are saying the same
thing they're all being given the same
message to talk about the past three
years was a very good example of that
because it was all the same on all that
what when when do all political stances
agree on one thing never but well in the
past three years that's what exactly
what happened they all agree if you
check their early life in education on
Wikipedia there you go
but um yeah this is why I don't have a
political stance I wouldn't say I'm
conservative and I wouldn't say I'm
liberal because I don't have a political
view I think there are two wings of the
same bird I'm not left-wing or right
wing I am the bird and I'm free
I've just well that's crazy I just yeah
I just I believe that news the
mainstream news just uh Propel Fierce
scarcity over over the world I mean it's
not even the aftable source for the
information as we can many things could
happen in the world positive such as
negative but why are we supposed to get
negative things just to be in scarcity
mindset because because they say in the
media they say if it bleeds it bleeds
negativity sells more than positivity
you know I mean I think we're well in
America like we are all guilty of like
when we see a car accident on the side
of the road we're driving we're like oh
[__] is anybody dead like yeah you know
it's like modern woman humble does a lot
better how to find a great wife you know
how to heal your traumas and be a good
man in 2023
where's feminists owned by alpha male
as humans drawn to negativity then I
think so I think so but also if you're
unfair if you're feeling negative
emotions like fear sadness worry you're
very easy to control because you're
looking for a leader to take control and
say Here's the solution listen to me
I'll get you out of this mess don't
worry about this I am your savior
everything I say goes listen to me now
and then people will automatically
because they're feeling this negative
low frequency emotion they will go to
the leaders and ask for a solution and
be and just basically do whatever they
say yeah and then they give up their
freedom every single time yep it's a
cycle it happens all the time you create
a problem you engineer a problem and
then you're like oh wait
I've got a solution right here you might
take this thing and become [__] but
that's okay
there is this undercover
um journalist it's like so funny I feel
like women are the best undercover
journalists just like getting a guy on a
date in an important Place yeah shout
out to project America
and I wish I could find it I was just
looking for it on my phone so if anyone
knows this video send it to me on
Instagram but it was like
um I feel like you probably saw it we're
on the same Twitter project Veritas was
it where the guy was saying how easy it
is to buy politicians oh I don't know he
he was like a Headhunter for like a
financial firm that managed like
something trillion dollars worth of
money and they were just saying like
politicians are so easy to buy and we
orchestrate the war in order to like in
Ukraine in order to make money because
it's good for politicians and the dude's
like admitting this to this girl on a
date I'm not surprised
um I actually know a politician I know
an MP who's now been kicked out of
parliament he's called Andrew bridgen
and he was speaking out against the
um jab and basically talking about all
the deaths and injuries it's causing in
Parliament and he compared it to the
am I allowed to say Hollow no okay he
didn't even know what you mean though
that event he compared it to the event
which happened during World War II that
you know who was in charge of
um and he basically was shedding a light
on the injuries and deaths from it and
he used that word
um and because he used that word the
media spun it and called him
anti-semitic and he was kicked out of
parliament for being anti-semitic and
for hating Jews basically which is so
not true it's not that's nothing to do
with what he said he was just using that
as a comparison to the deaths and
injuries caused by the jab
um so yeah he's now been kicked out of
parliament for having
it's like the the media will just sit on
your stream looking for a 30-second like
buzz clip yeah just to cancel your you
know pain and narrative like whatever
they want to push you out whether it's
racist sexist homophobic and it's just
people are going getting tired of it
people aren't stupid yeah well I think
the majority are actually because the
majority agree with no it is a lot of
keyboard Warriors there's a lot of
people that got a lot of time I was like
you think they've got a lot of time I
call them keyboard Warriors
and if you just sit there and they find
anything to start on yeah no it's it's
too much it's too much and they're only
tough online when you confirm
[Music]
rooms don't even have their faces on
them exactly
my point was Andrew bridgen
he knows he's spoken about this publicly
so I think I can say this he knows that
other MPS know what's going on but they
are they are not speaking out about it
because they don't want to lose their
job like he did yep so this is sick and
it's it just shows how you can get yeah
easily bought no oh gosh this weekend I
went to a volleyball tournament and they
had trans people playing in it and I go
to the director of the tournament and
I'm like you know this is wrong like a
girl is going to get hurt like we cannot
play with dudes and I could just see it
like he knew because I was talking to
him I could tell he knew what I was
saying was right but it's like he's like
no well I need to volleyball England I
just get my orders from volleyball
England they're probably going to kick
me out of the league like I I I think
I'm gonna be kicked out because they've
been telling me I have transphobic
tweets oh yeah yeah yeah if you're
pointing out the obvious that men and
women yeah and now and now I got footage
asking the girls
um interviewing the girls if they're
okay with this and you know some girls
were four I mean we just believe the
stupidest ideas like but some girls were
for it and most against but some for it
and they're not letting me or they're
saying I can't produce the like put out
the footage because I'm not allowed to
film on their property even though you
know it's crazy people feel do game film
all the time yeah and they told me today
that it was because of vulnerable adult
and children and I'm like one there were
no kids there so stop it and what's a
vulnerable adult probably the women
playing with the dudes yeah that's what
I would say but vulnerable like someone
that's not mentally mentally stable
basically is that what they mean I mean
I would say a dude with a boob job is
not mentally stable did they have boob
jobs there yes oh wow yes yes and there
was one team that was almost all dudes
it was like five we got we got footage
from it yeah did they win no no
so funny
no actually yeah they were some of them
some of them but it was so funny
no it was so it was so funny though
because you would see them do well but
like if the dudes did too well they
would kind of like back off because they
don't want too much attention what a
bunch of losers yeah you're gonna you
gotta commit if you're gonna do it do it
there was one team that had one and like
she was she he was the best one on the
team and they would just set him every
single ball and I'm just my friend like
hurt her finger there's another girl I
interviewed that said she heard her
thumb from it on a different tournament
I'm just like how are we there like I
went into the locker rooms they were in
there too so I'm like now I have to
share a locker room with grown men I
wasn't even playing in this tournament I
just needed to see this you know what I
mean I'm like and now yeah I gotta I got
a text if I had my other phone I would
read it I got a text today of them
saying Oh you can't
um
yeah you can't release the footage
because of the vulnerable vulnerable
adults and the children what are you
doing with this footage I just told them
I'm like yeah I'm talking about the
trans stuff yeah yeah and I don't know I
don't they don't even pay me that's the
crazy thing I'm like
I'm like I'm probably
I'm like one of the best players in the
sleep well I don't care like kick me out
yes if if I have nothing against trans
people if they were to you know
if that's what they want to do that's
fine they can do it but they should not
be
imposing on women taking over women's
sport groups or teams or just women's
sports in general because
we're biologically different it's just
the biological fact even if you go
through this exchange even if you change
even if you you know get boobs it
doesn't change the fact you're a
biologically born a male your whole body
is completely different to a woman's
body yeah you have more strength than we
do why are you trying to impose on our
Sports and win everything which is
what's happening have you not seen the
there's like men or biological man
winning women's
um yeah even tournaments I think in the
Olympics even
yeah it's basically men biological men
keep winning things that are meant for
women
um even
Beauty contests which is hilarious
because there was did you see the people
because when you when you when you look
at it too like though like there is
there is a financial component to this I
just sent Pro and infographic I don't
know if you could yeah I'm gonna send it
to King yes if you pull it up because
this is a growing industry and they talk
about dude Bill Maher did a very popular
segment on a show and it showed like the
increasing amount of homosexual people
in America and now like I think 20 of
these young kids identify as gay but I
said it earlier last week I said just
gay is the new goth it's like when you
have that goth kid you're like oh it's
okay he just you know hates his dad you
know he's in this goth stage and now
they're like oh yeah I'm this I'm that
and the reason why because they're
watching all the stuff that is like you
know there's a lot of propaganda about
this like you know you can't even go
some places you just go and you're like
I want to eat a sandwich like yeah but
do you love gay people
it's just like can I just order a
sandwich and like not like declare my
ideology you know and can I just say in
schools they are doing disgusting things
teaching children that they can yeah
um pleasure themselves reception
children who are about five years old
teaching them you can pleasure yourself
here's how giving them books on how to
pleasure themselves
like 70 different genders and also
recently there was um in a school where
current Butch school it was that there
were two girls who were questioning one
of the students in the in the classroom
saying
the student identified as a cat
right and then these two go stand up and
they say no I don't believe this is
right and the teacher's teaching them
how there's like 70 different genders
and then they stand up saying I don't
believe this is right I don't agree with
this yeah and then the teacher's like
how dare you this is disgraceful you've
just offended people in this class and
they're like I don't care this is what I
believe I don't believe that there are
70 genders I don't believe you can
identify as a cat I think if you do you
should go you should be put into a
mental Asylum which is true because that
means you're mentally unstable and the
teacher alienated them from the class
kicked them out of the class made them
go to the Head teacher to give a
statement about what about the hate
crime they've just
um conducted it is so sick and
um luckily they've had a lot of support
as opposed to what I thought it would be
they're trying to normalize delusion all
of the institutions are doing it UK and
us like when I was in the US we were one
of the first colleges to have trans
people they had them down the hall in
the dorms from us like they're trying to
normalize it and they're pushing it and
they're recruit like why are we
recruiting less than one percent of the
population go ahead can I play devil's
advocate of this as well say if I just
turned around she guys and I was like
okay so I actually identify as a cat why
is that a problem for you guys
it's not a problem it's just you can't
be a cat so if I say whether I can't or
not if I say let I identify as a cat I
mean why because it's because
why because here's a problem because now
you're forcing me to participate in your
delusion because your genome doesn't
identify as a cat you're a human yeah so
you can say you're [__] a cat or
whatever but the reality is you just
want attention from Mom and Dad your
parents probably [__] up and they're
probably white because if you're sitting
around saying you're a cat that's
typically white kids that are [__]
saying this [__] but you know it's it's
a big problem because now you're
imposing your perception reality on me
about my daily life and I'm like by the
way I'm a cat carry on my how is it well
but the thing is because you're because
you have to associate so so I get it but
you're not a cat okay I think we should
do it I think we should shame like I
think we should shame craziness in
public yeah yeah like I don't think it's
a kind no no you're fine I'm sure for
sure it makes it more interesting so I'm
glad you are but I don't I don't think
it's kind to pretend you're a cat I I
think it's kind to say go get help yeah
because you're not a cat you're never
gonna be a cat and getting surgery to
make you a cat it is probably not going
to help you in the long run and the
crazy thing is I interviewed a hormone
doctor when it comes to the trans stuff
a lot of them just have their hormones
off yeah and he's been working with
trans people for 20 plus years where
they thought they're the opposite gender
and then he fixed their hormones like
the guy the guys either had really low
testosterone or the woman had High um oh
wait sorry yeah yeah I don't I don't
know the hormones whatever it is
testosterone was low yeah women's
testosterone was high the restroom was
low yeah and that's a problem right now
because if you read the book called
estrogeneration The Chemicals and
everything we use nowadays are [__]
with our hormones like sunscreen right I
mean all these social excuse me all
these um shampoos conditioner pesticides
pesticides like it's in our food these
things are hormonally scrambling the
eggs of these people's minds and then
they're like and then to top it off you
have the chemical side of it right and
then you have the propaganda side you're
like oh wait yeah well I think uh I'm a
woman because if you look at what's
happening too in the states right
they're in the United States
1.4 million people identify as
transgender right
1.2 million of those people are male to
female no way wow
yeah and you propaganda and I I talk
about this too because when you have a
culture in America that's just like yeah
men are [__] men are trash [__] men men
are garbage men men men are awful and
then you know [__] have Ariana Grande
be like God is a woman and you have like
woman power women this women are the
best you know you be a CEO go to the
[__] moon have a children and then
like make a billion dollars and like
yeah you got a four-year Bachelor's in
gender studies you know they're like
selling women these gigantic lies and
just having this grandiose future
painted for them and on the flip side
you're like oh you're a man well like
just because you're a man you're evil
and bad and I remember when this all
started the first time I remember it
anyways was the Caitlyn General like
when she got that award and I I feel
like because we accepted that now we
have men taking women's titles now we
have men assaulting women in our
bathrooms yeah now and and do you know
what I hate when men say that we don't
have the right to our own bathrooms
because that is when as a woman you are
the most vulnerable and just because
some trans people won't do it it doesn't
mean none will and and one girl that
gets assaulted from that especially kids
is too many it's two men and and they
want us to just live in delusion and
pretend that they're the opposite gender
like someone asked me on a podcast do
you think you know Blair white would you
be comfortable with her in your bathroom
and you know I'm kind of a Blair white
fan like she's funny but it no I don't I
don't want trans people in our bathrooms
I'm not gonna
enable their delusion yeah and actually
there's loads of gay people who are
turning against the whole transgender as
well like if you've seen gays against
groomers they're speaking out against
this a lot because you know they were
just living their lives you know if you
couldn't I have no problem with people
choosing to live their lives a certain
way I wouldn't personally and I do yeah
I wouldn't do it personally
um but
now but if you
look at the amount of gay people who are
speaking out against us because it's
literally they're being put in one group
lgbtq yes it's everywhere McDonald's KFC
the the flags I just went to this coffee
shop down the road and there are all the
flags everywhere why I don't understand
why because because of a company called
BlackRock because BlackRock has a score
system called the ESG score which I mean
I think it stands for environmental
social governance score and if you do
not emphatically support gay people
during pride month you get a low ESG
score upon multiple aspects within this
score and if your score is low this
doesn't allow you to qualify to get
money and loans for your business like a
social credit system right but for
companies so like for example right one
of the companies that like scores really
high is like Bank of America and apple
and a company that scores really low is
Tesla and we look at Tesla like what
Elon Musk did when he took out that
gigantic quarter quarter of a billion
dollar loan from the United States
government I'm pretty sure it's 250
million he paid it back you know he
turned the entire
loan into a gigantic Global movement the
other companies are started like making
electric cars because of him
he's still demonized because his ESG
score is not that high so that's a big
reason why you see the pride stuff
everywhere it's because a company called
BlackRock and the CEO is Larry Fink and
they are the ones that are pushing this
thing and it's like they really don't
care all these companies they really
don't care about gay pride and all stuff
because if you look like BMW and they
look at BMW Saudi Arabia there's no gay
pride on the Saudi Arabia stuff well you
know what I mean and this is why people
have to speak out about this stuff early
because the more you allow the more
they'll do it all started with freaking
Caitlyn Jenner taking that award now we
have now we have men and women sports
now I go to a a rec league this weekend
there's five men on the court five crazy
but I think this is bigger than this
it's because they know I mean the system
or the Matrix if I'm allowed to label it
as it is they know that men if they're
awakened they're strong they're they're
a strength they cannot make like strong
men shut up or comply to what they say
so they make everything to just try to
make them uh uh submissive to what they
trying to
um to implement in all areas of life
through a propaganda of uh like
transgender people or like gay or many
other IG or like feminism as well just
to make men feel weak and vulnerable and
not to awaken that power in them to just
Revolt so they can make money as they
are and this is gonna come in handy for
them because in a few years time I would
say in around 10 years time I believe
we'll be living under a social credit
system worldwide I believe there's going
to be a one world government where they
try to implement
um horrible tyrannical measures onto the
public worldwide I believe they're going
to try and force people to have medical
procedures and if they don't they'll
have a low credit score like in China
right now
um I believe that they are going to say
that you can't have a certain amount of
meat
um because it's bad for the global
warming which is what they're going to
paint this as and they're going to have
men who submit to it because they're
being taught now to submit in advance so
that when the time comes they're more
likely to just say okay do you know what
I'm going to let this happen it's going
to make my life easier if I just comply
and shut up and don't say anything and
they're going to have less men who are
willing to stand up and fight and say
absolutely not not and that's why that's
why I think they've taken fathers out of
the home like why why do we have
policies that actively discriminate
against men why do we have policies that
put men in prison why do we have
policies that take can be on house
arrest for three years because one girl
said he did something why do we have
policies that pay with women to leave
marriages why do we have policies that
pay women to break up families it's
because they do not want strong men
because if they we had strong men they
cannot control it yeah can I stay this
just slightly no because so
you know a lot of the things we're
talking about is that you know all of
this is just to have I guess to weaken
men and that you know men are weak in
all of this but going back to that do
you not think that this is actually just
to weaken people both men and women yeah
because actually men and women we both
need each other as much you know as much
as a man needs a woman and vice versa so
we're saying you know actually this is
all a systematic thing that's taken down
men but actually if women were just as
woke about this we would all just be as
powerful do you not believe women aren't
moving on so I I think when men win they
win for everyone when women they win for
themselves can you explain that a bit so
so like when when men had all the like
more power in society like they they
still gave women rights and privileges
yeah so so I mean such as voting they
didn't men were the ones that built
Society right and they gave us the right
to vote but when women win we're very
selfish when we got the power to leave
our husbands we did and also who goes to
war men and women it's always men but
who starts the wars actually women no no
over the last 500 years women have waged
more Wars than men when it comes to a
percentage so like when women were in
power they wage war more which makes
that rock that would stop no no no I
said more men have been in power in the
last 500 years but I'm saying if you
look at it as a percentage basis so if
you look at like there was 10 women in
power it's a higher percentage that
women have started Wars
would you make sense we're more spiteful
come on like imagine a group of guys
living in a house versus labeled in like
the whole group of women because I don't
see I don't know I don't think I'm not
the same as you and win we have to make
generalizations in order to have a
conversation and I think there's like a
female nature that's where it gets a bit
tricky when we make generalizations do
you know I think we have to we have I do
we can't we can't make generalizations
because then it's your pre-judging
aren't you you're making like a
pre-judgment and I like to give
everybody the benefit of that and you
can do you're not the same as you and
vice versa do you think it's okay do you
think it's equal that men get along the
same way women get along and what that's
okay blank attempts you're gonna need to
dumb that down a little bit for me now
how could I dumb it down more than that
okay
[Laughter]
do you think women get along the same
way men get along so by getting along
though I think that's what I'm asking
you to dumb down because that's quite a
broad getting along what do you mean by
getting along do you mean just having a
conversation do you mean you know
undergoing Hobbies together what do you
mean by that not having disagreements
yeah so you think that women have
disagreed
I'm just trying to I think women
disagree with each other more than men
disagree with each other okay yeah I
think women are more catty I think women
are more spiteful I think women are more
conniving in general do you think that
comes from us being a little bit more
emotional yeah well I think we're we had
to be more socially like men bully each
other physically where I think women
bully each other emotionally more I
think we're just more like our weapon is
emotions we're man's a weapon is violent
and that's what makes that's what makes
us different as men and women isn't it
but I also believe that within each
person we have a lot of balance right so
we all have masculine and feminine
traits about us there's no one person
that's just entirely masculine and
there's no one woman or man that's
entirely feminine but I believe it's
having that balance but I believe men
and women are born in different like I
think I don't think it's equal when
we're born like it's a blank slate in
this Society we're not equal what do you
mean in this society that we've been
brought up in men and women on
yeah so so like I think men are better
leaders in general yes because they're
less emotional and they are able to make
uh clear decisions compared to women but
sometimes you gotta leave those beliefs
in Morocco when you come to the West I
know you can't say those things I think
sometimes say you need a little that's
where balance comes in though because
you need to have a little bit no no I
know I'm being I'm being sarcastic
things like that though as much as we're
saying like Okay so like men are better
leaders because they're not emotional
well actually I think you do need to
have a little bit of emotion there for
it to be a leader because you need to be
able to improvise with the people that
you are leading do you not agree with
that I just don't have anything I do not
want a commander-in-chief general
I'm not saying be soft and like cry all
the time but I'm saying have balance
that's the key here when you have
imbalance that's when you have problems
so there are plenty of male leaders who
have balance and it's it's only a tiny
bit of empathy which is needed in order
to be a good leader the majority should
be the street yeah but this is actually
an example of like you're telling men to
emote like women oh no I said balance no
but balance is like saying be more
emotional be more feminine it's it's
really it's a celebrity because here's
that thing right we say about men that's
a horrible thing that people say is that
men shouldn't cry that's a horrible
thing but actually if it's crying is a
natural emotion but I feel like now is
starting to get normalized like I see a
lot of things on social media about men
should should if they want to express
themselves then they should they want to
cry they should be alive but this is
it's the same conversation though it's
like telling men to emote like women
women cry so you're saying men be more
like a woman but it's natural to Christ
to women but why why is that assumed to
be like good
if it's troubling him and his natural
emotion is that they're they're
literally tears are welling up I'm not
gonna be like suck those tears up boy no
no but you got to be a real man and go
home and cry in secret and let nobody
right and it's yeah there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with it but I
think but there's nothing wrong with it
there's nothing wrong with it but this
this
[Music]
um
this media campaign to pushed dudes to
be more in tune with their emotions
listen anybody who lives based upon
their emotions is going to be a
guaranteed failure and that's why I said
that that is the key thing I think we're
all like not really grasping here is
that I'm saying balance because if
you're too emotional you're going to go
one way and if you don't have any
emotion at all you're going to go there
but also it's just having it so I agree
with you on that but at the same time if
you want to be a leader if you're too
emotional or you know you claim to have
these balances but if you show an
emotional side that side can be
manipulated against you
balance emotions emotional emotional
comes School tutors you don't have to
say that's what happens when men are not
someone that's mentally ill though
that's someone that's mentally ill
having emotion and displaying a little
bit of emotion I think is kind of
different
women
but you are because you are because
you're saying like like a woman no no I
didn't no you know you didn't say those
words you say have a balance he said
have a balance okay but you but you as a
woman so you're saying that from your
point of view so you're saying this is
the perfect wait wait you're saying this
is the perfect amount of emotional
balance whatever it is so emote like me
but men are not women I don't want
anyone to make like me first of all
because oh my God we'd be in a situation
no
um what I'm saying is it's just it's
having that bit of balance because
imagine how hard it must be for men
because there's a lot of pressure on men
in this society as well that they have
to constantly always be the strongest
person but let's be real as human beings
not everybody
I have a question for you so you you
keep talking about this balance so um
can you tell us how to I identify where
the line for the balance is I don't know
where the line is because I feel like
that's very subjective for every person
everyone everyone's gonna happen no but
that's the point exactly so everybody
because if you keep saying balance
balance for everyone it's going to be
different right even when a man tries to
be more emotional is is going to be in
front of
a certain woman right and he doesn't
necessarily know if he becomes this much
emotional if you're going to put that
woman off that's his problem exactly
that is why men are asked to be more
stoic because then you you tend to
remove all those and how and how much
pressure does that put on a man if he
has to come it doesn't matter no
beautiful pressure that's the point yeah
but these days people try to tell men
that we shouldn't do what we're built
for our ancestors had to run miles to
look for food how answers not had to run
miles to look for water they had to
fight wild animals but today we're
telling men you need to cry more I'm not
telling no man to Crime up I'm saying no
I didn't I said to have balance and I've
also said that it is okay
but let me ask you this to have balance
not to be more emotional so so okay
so so balance according to you as we've
just discussed is
Savannah let me ask you something so
okay you say guys need to be more
balanced and have logic and an emotion
right but looking at the history of the
West and society as it is right now
those men have been typically more
logical and less emotional what's wrong
with Society right now because it seems
right now as we're making this shift to
men being more emotional everybody's
unhappy no matter unhappy the women are
unhappy you know it's not working out I
think
I think where it comes from is is maybe
balance might not have been the correct
word but what I'm saying is is it's okay
if a man needs to feel upset and he
needs to cry I think my point is is that
we are constantly telling people what
actually no deny that part of yourself
that human nature that that part of
yourself that needs to do that and I
don't think that's okay I think as I
said it puts so much pressure on young
men to constantly be strong yes you may
I don't think we are I don't I don't
think we're telling men not to cry and I
mean I would say I would say wait wait I
would say I would say in my in my show
maybe we do but in general in the media
no they tell men to be more emotional
again
recently even but even now in the show
you're telling men to be more emotional
than they were in the past you're saying
it's okay to cry so that that um that
equates to you can be more emotional
than they previously were so again it's
pushing men to emote more like women I
don't have a different way of processing
things to men we're completely different
in that way
what works for us is crying and then
taking time out and then you know
processing things however we do
um for men that actually brings him
further down if you're like I I know
this from experience from talking to
people to men
um
they if if they allow themselves to
become too emotional or more emotional
than usual it makes them even more
depressed it makes them even more
depressed and it makes them not be able
to find that solution which they would
be able to if they had that stoicism to
sort of carry on pushing and then that
takes them out of the sadness in the
first place because the thing which
makes them sad they found a solution for
by not wasting time laying around crying
so I think actually it's more damaging
to push the be more sensitive and cry
more because that actually is causing
them to not be able to find solutions
for themselves I I think I understand I
had a comment that said the highest
personality traits required to be
successful is conscientiousness and
disagreeableness Men possess that and
that leads to less emotional outputs and
the more emotional you tell men to be
the less of a chance that man has to be
a successful leader making them more
feminine we don't process emotions the
same
very true yeah
the reality is men have testosterone
right and what does testosterone do like
at the very basis of it the biological
nature of testosterone if it helps to
build muscle it helps to build denser
bones and these are all things you need
to do very strenuous physical activities
so that being said when a man feels like
he's down or he feels like he's sad or
depressed the best possible way for him
to let that out is through physical
exercise to your physical activity not
through crying yeah I'm not by the way I
think this has slightly been miscontrued
a little bit because I've not said that
a man has to cry I never once said that
what I said is it's okay to do that that
is what I've said I've not said that
every person and I don't understand
where this misconstrues has come from
either so it's either you're hearing
what you want to hear or you're just not
trying to understand what I'm saying
here but what I am saying is that it is
okay to do that if we tell somebody no
you shouldn't cry if that's what you're
naturally trying to do that's where that
pressure comes from 100 agree men have
testosterone that is the way you know
you release your your anger your
emotions whatever women have a way of
crying some women also work out because
actually women also have testosterone
too not the same levels but I think
that's what I'm trying to get at and
actually I'm I'm actually being an
advocate for men here by having that
empathy there because I think it's fair
that we put so much responsibility on
men all the time so that's where I'm
coming from with that whatever your
catharsis is your way of releasing that
is your way of doing it as I said it's
subjective I would say crying is natural
natural and if that's not if that has to
happen
it will happen that's my point men don't
need to be told to do it because if it
is a natural reaction it will happen
regardless of whether it tries to stop
it I think what the girls were saying is
that right now mainstream Society is
telling men's to prioritize being
emotional um
I'm not saying that I know I know and I
know that you know I think that's where
we're having a miscommunication here so
you have the social media companies and
I was like be vulnerable do this cry to
your girlfriend you can cry to your
girlfriend she's gonna leave you she's
she's not gonna
true really tell me a guy that cried to
you and you stayed with him
my ex-boyfriend ex-boyfriend
thanks so much he's an ex because he
cheated on me he's not an ex because he
cried to me like I I would want my
partner to be comfortable enough to come
and speak to me when he feels down how
old is he
we was how old was we my 17 I was living
for two years he's a child still no and
also that's um
to you you will have forgiven him for
cheating
that's fine like I I used to think that
you know men being emotional is really
attractive and you know it's them being
vulnerable and that means that they
trust you enough I don't want a man that
is
an emotional wreck don't get twisted
right I can't have a man that's always
crying to me this this and that no no no
no no no no no how much crying is too
much crying but when [__] really does
hit the fan I don't want you to just
how much crying is too much crying how
much crying every week every other day
okay so how many how much crying can he
do
once a year once again
I would actually think just cry over
things that I don't know like that
should be cried over maybe like if a
parent died or something like that but I
don't know here's the here's the issue
you said should be cried over yeah and
so then it's subjective and every woman
a guy is gonna deal with is gonna have a
different bar for what what is too much
and what is it so instead of you know
testing the waters it's just easier for
them to avoid the headache yeah you know
because because too emotional is going
to be different for each girl yeah right
yeah yeah
if they can prioritize for for example
if the message was when a man gets angry
go and work out like imagine if the
mainstream media was uh advertising this
rather than when you're upset just go on
everybody with jacked they'd be super
jacked exactly let me ask you this what
about Morocco are they like go out there
and cry never mind I mean this is not
how I was raised that's why for example
when the message of Andrew Tate is here
it's completely normal to me because
this is something my brother would say
my father would say my my cousin it's
not something new or something very well
shocking to the to the to me you know
what's interesting
the mate people would freak out if
someone just said serve your husband
you're supposed to serve your husband
that's how but it's so normal from like
actual traditional households but then
they'll be like you know to her they're
like oh you're just you're a dumb
Moroccan girl this is how we do it here
in the most [__] up Society of the
West you know what realization I had I
was like when I hear girls come on the
show and say oh I just gave him I did so
much for him like all this I realized I
was like it's actually the biggest red
flag for the girl because that means
she's keeping score oh yeah it shouldn't
be like that yeah when you're like as a
lady as a female when you're in a
relationship you're supposed to do these
things you shouldn't be tapping it oh
we're so loyal to him I've done this for
him I cooked for him I think it's normal
I love it as well I flew her here I did
that wouldn't be here without me you're
keeping score right now
[Laughter]
marriage is supposed to be like selfless
yeah like it's supposed to be you give
as much as you can and you don't you
don't worry about the other side because
a lot of times like as girls we don't
always think about the stuff they do for
us because we're so self-centered really
I love it when a guy does like little
things to me even if it's just like a
text or he comes to pick me up yeah I
mean I'm not talking I'm not talking
about you personally I'm just saying in
general that's why I say we can't really
make generalizations though I mean no
difference well it's like when you start
to talk to hundreds of people in a year
you just start to see patterns yes
but
um yeah I just had that realization
though the other day I was like it's
actually a red flag when she's saying
how much she did for him because it's
like well he didn't do anything for you
but yeah yeah come on and you'll say you
should be enjoying it and enjoying
serving your partner
um instead of thinking of it like a
chore like oh I did this because I had
to no it's not because you had to if
you're in love with a man you
should if you would want to you
generally want to do that for the manual
exactly you don't sit there and you
start like making marks down and I've
done this I've done that he needs to do
that for me it doesn't work like that if
you generally love someone you want to
give them the world yeah that's that's
how it should be that's how I that's how
I see it personally that's how when I've
grown up that's how I've seen my parents
actually my parents relationship was not
the best but my mum
held it down for a very very long time
for the sake of me and my little sister
and that just showed me
as a lady marriage is very very very
precious and you do do the most for the
person you love even if they're not the
greatest
how common do you think false
accusations are
oh what what do you think is more common
a man being falsely accused or a woman
not being believed
both I think their wife is bad we gotta
act more common it's like we gotta pick
one I think
um I think a man being accused a man
being accused definitely a man being
accused what do you think man being
accused of something versus not someone
not believing a woman yeah well I get
people like biologically like you know
will believe woman no matter what like
it's consider nature to like protect
women you know what I mean like as men
like if you if you ever watched any like
world star video or like a dude punches
a chick in a public place like 50 dudes
swarm on that guy so psychologically
it's kind of the same way I mean
that's a good question I don't know I
really don't know that's a good one
maybe I would say I mean I know what I'm
supposed to say
no I mean give me your honest opinion if
you don't I don't know just sitting
around thinking about it right now I
don't know because
I know that there have been a lot of
cases recently coming to light of women
around the globe pretending to be
innocent when they're not I've seen a
lot of those come to light and the other
side of this coin is like the women if
they're not listened to or believe then
it doesn't make any headlines so it's
hard to say except for oh yeah you know
yeah I agree sorry I know
it's uh it's kind of a sword with two
edges like men are typically uh accused
of even false things and they're they're
not even given the chance to defend
themselves but women when they do this
they're uh or when they are not um how
can I say that when they're not
um when when they are not innocent and
they pretend to be but they're given
credit for this I mean it's kind of a
sword with you to edit it do you know do
you know what case I was thinking about
recently I'm bad yeah that too that too
I was thinking of Weinstein
the real victims or the girls that
didn't take the role I'm like wait so
wait let me get this straight these
girls slept with him got famous and now
we're gonna paint them as victims why'd
you sleep with him he wouldn't be able
to do what he did if all the chicks
didn't sleep with him but there was no
accountability on the women it was only
on the men like the real victims or the
women that didn't get the parts did he
actually grape them or would just like
let's just do this they're like sure I
want to be a star it was it was um he
was exchanging sex for roles
so is that illegal
if he was graping them I get it was that
the chart why is he in jail for that
that's what I thought it was I don't
know
for me there's no
there's no there's no amount of money no
opportunity that any man could offer me
for sex 100 I could be offered in my
life I could be offered a billion pounds
and I would say yeah no if I don't love
him no I'm not doing it regardless
because to me
my dignity and my
um
Steam
no I cried I can't think of the word not
even Pride just my it's like uh pureness
yeah my Purity is more
important to me than any amount of money
because money can't buy that and I'd
rather literally live on a hill with
some cows
and and a family and not have to think
that I actually you know gave my body
away for money or for this or for gain
like so for me there's literally no
amount of money anyone could pay me to
do that so if they're choosing to if
that's what happened I don't know what
the case is but if if that is the case
and they chose to sleep with him and he
didn't grape them he took they chose to
sleep with him for a role
I what do you what do you think of women
that come out years later and accuse a
guy of grape
yeah that's just [__] up I mean
because it's just like if if it happened
I get it but what are the statutory
limits on that
what are the like you know what's the
legal limit on that and then also it's
just like if you're saying something
happened in the 70s like how are you
gonna prove it yeah like I don't have a
[__] DeLorean are you guys familiar
with the Jimmy Savile case who's that
Jimmy's
Jimmy's having sex
actually Tate mentioned it earlier on so
to give you like a small synopsis he was
again like this sort of like presenter
and years later similarly a load of
women came out and was just like yeah he
did XYZ like all of this stuff to me
um and I thought the same thing I was
the same as you guys I was like why the
hell did they not just say something
while he was alive you could have easily
put him in jail then do you know what I
mean you could actually question him but
then you know they started to speak out
about the fact that
people just wouldn't believe him that
that was where it came from because this
guy was like so loved by the British
public if they were to come up and be
like well Jimmy saviled like he did this
to me and touched me here and that and
the other they were just literally
getting shut down and people were like
you either being attention seeking or
they were like well that's just Jimmy
Savile and I think that's where it comes
from where like a lot of these women
don't speak out at the time it's through
fear yeah if you don't try it over but
how do you but they're not thinking like
that if you're scared and it's like some
you really have to put yourself in
someone's shoes to understand this if
someone's really really scared and
there's somebody very powerful like this
prince Andrew stuff that's going on
right yeah you're not gonna openly just
be like yeah this is what happened and
that happened because look what we were
talking about the CIA and all of these
people that can just hunt you down and
kill you whatever people are scared
especially if you don't come from do you
think you have to have like I was
thinking about it no I was more thinking
that I think we have to have like you
have to file it within three months
that's what I think because I just think
we're in a sticky it's not a perfect
system but I I just figured a sticky
situation where you can come out years
later and accuse someone of something
as well Bill Cosby I think that's
another example of that right like yeah
I think unless it's like miners maybe
like I I think you should there has to
be something where you have to come out
at the time
um someone said about the Harvey
Weinstein they said they said it was
great but then when it came out they
said it was an exchange and then some
said it was great but the stories
changed once it was out in the public
eye at first it was up in the air and
Rose mcgorman who led the me to char
charge took settlements
um is he in jail though
I feel like he is isn't he uh let me
look I can look
um I think so things that he connected
with Epstein as well yeah but I don't
know I just think there should be equal
energy if you're taking sex for a part
should she be in jail isn't she doing
the same thing yeah because he's
leveraging power but she's leveraging
beauty isn't she doing the same thing
yeah no she she is yeah so it's like
Constitution yeah yeah it is it's
prostitution but it's like but it's like
these women are what they're victims
when you gave him no if they gave the
man consent to be recorded and for them
to do what I was doing
I don't think
um they should cross it as whether it
was classed as unless I don't know maybe
a knife was put to their neck and they
was forcefully made to consent then I
don't know and that classifies as grape
uh I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second
um guys make sure you like the video
there's over 2 000 of you in here so
let's get to Let's a thousand likes we
open up the chat so make sure you get it
to a thousand but I really think we
should get a thousand five hundred likes
a like is free also guys
um make sure you sign up for our Google
form um that should be pinned in the
chat
um we're gonna do meetups in London and
probably the us too when we go there
also guys
um
make sure
you subscribe to the channel because
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
sorry I'm pulling up the super chats
okay okay okay all right 90 free-tail
pie if women fought against the Nazi we
would lose oh why would you do that to
me why would you do that to me
[Laughter]
um they spelled the difference
off of YouTube
sometimes they'll roast someone and I
don't realize like I don't comprehend
what I'm reading until after and it'll
be so mean and I'm like
but it's like I I sometimes it takes me
a second surgery Kudos Pro for having a
panel of sane people for once everyone's
saying
um Amar uh Miss um no common sense
nothing is done yet miss m
you want us to stay if they beat us but
not if they cry okay I did not say to
leave anybody if they cry I just said
women are more likely too all right I
did not do not put that on me dragon
stallion one zero zero one how long
until you lose respect from the man and
leave if he cries because he had a bad
day at work or JoJo was picking on him
Lawrence uh prison is full of emotional
men a full we taught this shows that
Miss Andrea um that men go through once
a man is Accused he is treated as guilty
he loses the job thrown in jail and
loses his life also men are not made for
emotional balances our brains are wild
up wired oppositely
I miss um he's guilty y'all are a
betrayal to the female gender
I'm a betrayal to the female hey that's
that's okay keep paying to tell me that
that's okay that's okay
[Applause]
Leon vrp men are demonized so they can
form a resistance they take down the
castle walls so that they can take Jules
AKA children with no resistance Dragon
stallion one zero zero one
Black Rock recruiter claims Senators we
bought for 10K were good for business uh
James O'Keefe article let me see if I
can find this on Twitter because that
was actually such an interesting video
that was recent yeah no I just saw it
today I wish I thought I favorite that
was that company I told you about
BlackRock oh okay wait oh Black Rock let
me see if this comes up because I want
to react to it if
oh yeah it's on King it's on James
O'Keefe Twitter can you find it just
look up BlackRock on Twitter
um okay Leon vrp people don't believe in
the elite stuff because they can't
comprehend the level of evil that's
going on on at the Top Evil is very real
uh Leon sartorio life dating Leon vrp
MLD in the house been binging your
channel lately the inner game stuff is
superb shout out to John and check it
out everybody uh Robert matu it's men's
mental health month Kings uh I think I
read the other ones I'm gonna refresh it
really quick uh guys I think we're close
to opening up the chat we're at 955
likes 50 more of you and we'll open up
the chat
um
okay let me just double check uh who
they don't want to be Amar who hurt you
cough cough miss m uh 90 free-toe pie on
my man in the blue that Asian chick was
out of line you did nothing wrong she
was emotional and hurt by the weight
comment
he's talking about I know what you're
talking about the name that shall not be
named I actually don't even know that
chick's name exactly
exactly you have the video king
yeah I saw this on Twitter earlier it's
basically I swear that's what I would do
the same thing if I wanted information
out of someone I would just send a
pretty girl
[Laughter]
so I guess this is
yeah you can pull it up that that's the
one yeah
okay I guess while I figure sites some
film but I suspect it's fun
it's really loud use this though that
it's like matching with the stuff you
showed in the news because they said
like Fox
and so it's kind of like when they have
Tate's name on a list they just all go
for him yeah but the people that they
don't pick they'll kind of spin the news
the way they want to spin it so like the
guy Andrew Schofield banned from Uber
and Airbnb Phillips Phillip Schofield is
he banned from wow that's not so crazy
no because Andrew's banned from Uber
Discord Airbnb man who breeds even yay
like his bank accounts all got banned
really good question he criticized ye
who shall not be criticized yes he
hasn't been banned what he probably
hasn't been bad oh oh yeah okay
it would have been on the news if it but
it's like what are these people's agenda
like why are they pushing why why are
they pushing this gay stuff why are they
pushing trans people why are they
pushing men to be weak why are they
pushing all of this machine show that
chart I sent you about the uh oh yeah
yeah yeah show the show the charts if
you take a look at the transgender why
are they pushing policies for like
women's empowerment why are they pushing
policies that for single mother homes
because I mean if you track it all like
it goes down to money because here's the
the way the Fiat currencies system is
set up you have to continue to print
money to keep the Ponzi going and you've
got to keep putting this money into
certain areas of the economy I mean
we've had the whole pandemic situation
right you had like
billions and billions and billions of
money just print it because that's the
only way you keep this thing going it's
a fiat currency system and that's why
all these companies are absolutely
adamant against cryptocurrency and in
addition to what we just see here with
BlackRock BlackRock is now filing for a
Bitcoin ETF and BlackRock and a lot of
these other financial institutions are
starting to get legally
um they're gonna they're moving to get
the majority control of a lot of
cryptocurrencies so they can control
this and manipulate it as well at the
same time they're trying to ban cash I
don't know if you've noticed but loads
of shops are going cashless yeah so
they're trying to stop you from using
cash so that you're unable to have you
know control over your own finances if
everything's digital who's in control of
the internet not us so they can shut off
the internet they can shut down your
bank account so you can't even access
your own money if if they take away cash
and cryptocurrency it is so dangerous
and it's a massive slippery slope to a
very very sad world where we're being
controlled in every aspect of Our Lives
because that's how they're going to use
I don't know if you've heard about the
trucker protests yeah in Canada in
Canada so during the pandemic people
were being pressured into taking the jab
and they were protesting against the job
and they were in their trucks on the
highways blocking the highway so that
people couldn't get through to say I'm
not taking this job and you can't force
me and you can't take away my rights if
I choose not to take it and and then
look and then when you go back to the
money thing right so that's that's the
projected growth of
um you know what's gonna happen there
and it's funny too how they have the
disparity there in the beginning of they
they have it like it looks like the
majority of people doing it too is
female to male Oh I thought you said it
was the other one no no so so it is
but getting the surgery uh
because a lot of because you can still
claim to be transgender and not get the
surgery well the guy's surgery I mean
did you see the that video of that girl
the girl guy talking about after he got
the surgery it's it's like it's really
dangerous and like it's there's all this
you can have applications that come with
it and if they don't keep like I forgot
what it was but if they don't do
something like gross like to keep her um
dildo kind of thing yeah inside for a
few hours a day I think that it
stretches out I think you have to yeah
you have to constantly like put
something inside it so it doesn't close
up yeah because your hole is basically
like a gaping flush and what I realized
is these people are trying to play God
because they they want to decide when
someone's guilty or innocent they don't
want to look at the facts they want to
decide when someone's a man or a woman
they want to decide when life begins
they want to decide they want to put
birth control in our bodies which Frick
like they [__] us up you know 90 of
women have been on birth control at some
point in their life yeah 90 and most of
us it's marketed to us when we're 16 and
they don't even tell us like how crazy
it makes us it's a class one carcinogens
that actually can cause cancer and if
you look at the cancer rates they are
rising like we've never seen before like
yeah and we wonder why that is but it's
all of the chemicals in our food all of
the things that are being sprayed on us
all the medication that we take all the
medication that we take and yeah birth
control is a massive contribute
contributor to that I think because if
you look at yeah like you said Pearl 90
is a massive number but going back to
the truck is protests so they were
protesting against the jab and Justin
Trudeau the prime minister of Canada he
froze their bank account so they
couldn't use their finances and the
shops in close proximity were all cut
card only so they couldn't even like buy
food or water for themselves and he was
trying to force them to stop protesting
by taking away their finances that's why
yeah but if we have cash or
cryptocurrency this will never happen
like we won't be in that situation so we
have to make sure that we obviously you
know fight to keep our Financial Freedom
then I killed a guy that owns Bitcoin no
no man independently owns Bitcoin it is
a peer-to-peer cashless Network oh I
just found out they don't know who the
shitho Satoshi Nakamoto it's like
someone Alias yeah they don't know who
it is yeah yeah wow so what was that on
the nose where somebody
um got killed and apparently he was the
owner of crypto or Bitcoin the
one of the men who was killed recently
was I think was it the founder of Cash
app uh yes oh yeah was it for him he was
stabbed in San Francisco yeah I'm not
entirely sure but on the cash app you
can buy Bitcoin but I'm not entirely
sure I'm pretty sure the chat will
probably correct me but I'm pretty sure
it was the founder of Cash app yeah that
was killed he was stabbed in San
Francisco I believe Chad helped me out
let me know
if the guy is down there
um that's true yeah yeah do
um a sad confession by Jazz Jennings on
on YouTube King
yeah cash up what was his name Robert I
think his name was Robert
was it like a few weeks ago because
that's when I saw it it was about a
month or so again then it must be that
then
yeah actually everything is linked to
the financial system yeah yeah
I mean we were fine when we were
operating on the gold standard basics in
the financial system well now we're
getting good look at that go ahead but
once we moved to the Fiat money and
fractional Reserve banking it's all been
a mess and even feminism and man being
weak and women empowerment it's coming
to a tax bracket I think in the western
world where they're trying to generate
two household with two incomes with two
taxes so they do their best to separate
men and women and just this illusion of
uh Independence you're the prettiest
girl I've ever seen talk about this
stuff all the other crypto girls
but yeah that's that's that that's
exactly true when you get off the gold
standard why because now you could
endlessly yeah print that money just
turn that money printer on
money is just a promise like even on
notes in the UK it says I promise to be
to pay the better on demand the sum of
five pounds or ten pounds or 20 pounds
it literally says I promise to pay on
the note so the the note itself is a
promise to pay it's not actually it has
no value itself yes it's called a
promissory note exactly yeah which is
true it's what it is but when you look
back at everything it's like I thought
I've been saying this in the show since
last week but every time you see some
social movement or some hashtag movement
or some government policy nine times out
of ten
it's connected to more money
or more votes that they don't give a
[__] about us if they give a [__] about
us they want to lock this up like
prisoners for two years then it forced
us to take some experimental thing in
our shoulders you know and kill a lot of
people who've died from that uh I'm
gonna show you guys what we're talking
about earlier Jazz Jennings
complications from her
the surgery
um this is Matt Walsh covering it I
don't know where the original one is but
it's yeah there you go
uh Breitbart it says after eight seasons
four sex change surgeries quote unquote
and countless hormone treatments TLC's I
am Jazz star Jazz Jennings still doesn't
feel right I don't feel like me ever
Jennings revealed in a recent episode
Jazz Jennings was born a boy and
declared himself transgender at the age
of five confess feelings of
dissatisfaction to his mother Jeanette I
just want to feel like myself all I want
to be is happy and feel like me I don't
feel like me ever
uh Jazz set an emotional exchange caught
on camera so this
reality show is still ongoing and Jazz
Jennings has been
um
quote unquote living as a girl
now for years
but isn't happy I think we have the clip
of that let's watch it so um are you
feeling like you wanted to start talking
about
are you okay I'm okay I'm gonna cry
you know I can't get out of my yeah I
know no listen
it just doesn't stop it's okay it's okay
I know what you're going through we've
been nervous no it still doesn't stop
now and I'm already going back to
negative but the more you're talking
about yourself it gets harder you're
digging in and you're it's making you
put a magnifying glass on what's already
difficult as it is
so this is hard for you I know and you
don't we don't want to push it I know
I'm the one doing it like I know you're
almost enemy
I feel kind of all over the place and
like my mind is very cluttered and not
clear and I really want to have that
Clarity I really want to understand
myself and be able to read my own soul
and what I want and it's just very
challenging and I think I'm kind of
breaking down a little bit and spiraling
into negativity
I just want to feel like myself like
that's it I don't care all I want is to
be happy and feel like me and I don't
feel like we ever
uh okay so that's
actually in a really depressing and
terrible way it's it's a powerful clip
because of the words that he uses I
don't feel like myself ever I don't feel
like myself
now you hear from the abusiveness this
mother I mean obviously all these
parents that Force this on the kids are
all evil but this woman in particular
white women you know it's different for
her because we've seen this has been
we've seen this documented she has
documented herself psychologically
abusing and uh brainwashing and
conditioning her son to believe himself
to be a girl we've seen this over the
years
and uh so you can see just how
evil this woman is now she says I've
been through it I know it no you haven't
really you've been through that
your son is mutilated beyond recognition
and he's gone through with the whole
quote-unquote sex change
I literally unless there's more footage
but I literally think that's child abuse
it is how old is this uh Jazz Jennings
person it's like uh I think 15 to 18 no
I think I mean maybe older I think
really but let me tell you something
when you take it when you take it would
say something real quick when you take
that's when you take they can't
transgender at five no I know but how
old is that person right now ah judge
Jenning H now
I can't find it hold on it's just when
you take when you take a bunch of these
hormones from 22. when you take a bunch
of hormones exogenously because I'm on
testosterone replacement therapy so I
take shots and then if you don't balance
your shots and you don't balance your
hormones your hormones determine your
perception of reality and a lot of
people don't realize that and when you
are because we are really governed by
our hormones I mean that's why they say
like you know when women get their
period like oh she's hormone I'm
hormonal I'm hormonal right you're like
angry or you're emotional or whatever
that looks in my opinion to like you
know somebody who is struggling with
their perceptions reality because your
body is biologically one way and if
you're constantly most most likely
taking injections of estrogen and
whatnot you know that literally [__]
with your reality and I think the mom is
manipulating him
I mean he's literally she's literally
gaslighting him yeah like she's saying
oh oh I know what you're going through
like like Matt Walsh was saying no you
don't this is child abuse and women that
let their kids do this and I've noticed
it's mostly women and there's a study
that came out recently that literally
said the majority or it's like half of
women whose kids transition have some
sort of mental disorder
and apparently after you
um transition you're more likely to
commit suicide after the transition so
they say oh you should let them do it
because otherwise they might kill
themselves if they don't I just have a
gut feeling okay you go to these drag
shows all the time is it women
yeah but is it women or is it women or
men that bring the kids or is it both
um both I would say they bring their
kids okay so basically what happens is
there's
parents bringing their kids to something
called a drag queen story hour so it's
drag queens reading books to
babies literally babies like from the
age of zero to two I think that's why
but it's not just reading because there
are literal videos of recordings inside
the buildings of the drag queens wearing
pretty much nothing it's actually on my
Instagram
um my Instagram Veronica if you want to
see the video Don't plug your stuff no
I'm just I'm stuck to watch the video
because it's seriously sick they are
unpold that they're doing pole dancing
in thongs fishnets stripper boots
um in front of babies and it's like why
would you want my biggest thing is this
too like I've seen a bunch of like
they're dressed like demons I'm like why
like why are you dressed like the devil
entertainment and it's fine if you if
you're an adult and you want to go to it
that's fine if that's your thing go and
do it but to bring children and babies
to why are you normalize I literally
think we should prosecute parents so do
that I believe that's how strongly I
feel about it because it's one thing if
you want to live in your delusion by
yourself it's one thing if you want to
be a left just do all that crazy [__] I
don't care do your thing but when you
when you put your indoctrination on your
children that that's where I have an
issue yeah and they'll say that the
right is so or I'll say right political
parties don't matter but they'll say
like conservatives like are so crazy for
saying leave the kids alone but it's
true you don't see conservatives doing
this yeah it's illegal to bring a child
or a baby to a club or a strip club yet
why is it okay
yeah yeah why does that make it okay and
why is it it's a good point and the
police are there and they don't do
anything they just allow it so you so
you'd protest these drag queen story
hours what do you do you just go outside
and hold a sign like go home [__] that
too but we do like speeches explaining
to them why it's wrong because there's
basically there's antifa who come yeah
yeah antifa comes to the Auntie what's
the next one I want to go
deeper comes and then they stand right
outside the place that we can't go in to
stop it yeah and then they're like
telling us that we're Nazis oopsie Daisy
we are um good save
that yeah fascists
um and other things which is oh yeah
okay yeah just calling us names for
literally just standing up for children
and babies yeah um and then they kind of
it's like a counter protest to our
protest saying that it's okay and that
we're like disgusting people for
opposing it did they beat up antifa in
this country like they do in America no
we beat them up in America I mean the
police are right there in between us so
if we were to do that we'd just get
arrested government funded great yeah
but it's exactly exactly it's adorable
it's really crazy but um yeah that's
whatever the Matt Walsh documentary what
is a woman who's seen that I want I've
seen parts of it okay they they did a
documentary where they essentially like
went into all these gender studies
professors and all these like super woke
people that don't believe in any gender
differences and he asked them what is a
woman
oh and they just couldn't answer
they're like whatever someone feels like
they are that day like they was just
yeah because how would you answer that
if you don't believe there's a
difference between the Sexes yeah that
was about Walsh's best work that was so
funny
do you think that
oh why do you think America got that
basketball player Brittany Greiner
out of prison
but they didn't try to get Tate out of
Romanian prison even though he's an
American citizen Tate just knows too
much like he is on to something and the
Matrix just
he's probably gonna just get killed real
soon as well
yes too obvious if not now a year down
the line the hundreds do you think 10
years ago no I feel like if he goes into
no I feel like if he goes yeah they did
it to Epstein
these people not later though what I'm
not saying they won't do it I'm saying
if they do it now it's a bit too obvious
I feel like if he went into jail like he
was guilty bit obvious they could make
it seem like he committed suicide or
something in jail or somebody tried to
hurt him in jail it's possible these
people are so powerful
is that they can do whatever they want
to do that's the truth I didn't say they
win I was just saying I just don't think
they'll do it right now I think it'll be
too obvious yeah I think maybe in the
years yeah I mean looking at information
just looking at the situation because
there's
in the Romanian justice system there's
no jury do you guys know that wow it's
just a judge so you you and the judge
and your lawyers got to convince the
judge and the prosecutor prosecutor is
some woman too she's like trying to make
her name off of Tate too so I mean if
that is I mean it's they're definitely
fighting an uphill battle but you know
knowing the Tates they're gonna [__]
fight to the very end because their
lives related it goes back to they saved
the lesbian basketball player yeah but
they won't save the masculine guy it's
like the same pattern she was guaranteed
guilty too yeah you know because uh that
basketball player doesn't expose Dark
Secrets of the Matrix that's what it is
well and it's crazy because she kneeled
for the national anthem yeah but wasn't
she like really that kind of
anti-American yes and so we're saving
the chick who's anti-america she's not
influential yeah that's the difference
who cares what a wnb yeah
like does anyone anyone watch the WNBA
know I don't even know where to find him
and I'm
I know it's like they they don't
they'll always push what's the opposite
of traditionalism like they'll always
push what what puts like men and women
against each other like they'll never
push policies and push people that
promote families yeah that's that's what
I was saying earlier too how like at
first it was just like gay people man
it's like gay and lesbians now it's gay
lesbians and bisexual and now gay
lesbian bisexual trans now
intersectional now queer now plus and
now a and because the thing is this the
more they can just cut you up and divide
us into 9 700 genders and all these
different things they can just make us
all separate and hate each other and we
can't all look up and be like wait
they're trying to [__] us well and the
other thing too in a lot of these like
cases like these me too cases they
expand the definition of abuse yeah so
it used to be abuse used to be like he
hit you in the face or he actually raped
you but they've added things like
coercion sexual assault So like
um there's even cases where a girl
basically said no to sex and then she
changed her mind boom now it's coercion
or if a girl's drunk then basically like
she can accuse him of graping her but
not vice versa if they're both drunk and
so it's like they expand the definite
definition of sexual assault and so we
don't even know what it means anymore
yeah like what what is sexual assault
doesn't cohesion just mean to force
though it just the literal definition is
false
well pressure
um someone into doing something
okay but basically I mean I guess
because the way they argue it it's weird
the way they argue it it's like because
he's stronger she was intimidated
[Music]
I mean and then they add in even in
abuse they'll say like um Financial
abuse so like he doesn't let her spend
five thousand dollars on the credit card
because she's abused
and then they also can go back and
basically say that he um
I didn't want to like I I I read some of
these case files and in the divorce
documentary and they'll even have like
one of the guys that I interviewed she
um they they slept together early in the
marriage it was like the first time and
then they were married for like seven
years they got divorced she claimed that
she was graped the first time they had
sex seven years later and it stood up in
court crazy I mean but it's different
because I don't Criminal Court is
different than a family court because in
Family Court like it's not based on
evidence it's based on a balance of
probabilities so it's not it's it's
easier to convict someone in Family
Court basically
[Music]
well
but and I just think like and it's
unfortunate because I think all of these
false accusations they take away from
real victims yeah from like the real
women that are actually abused and it
makes it harder for them like the real
women that actually have been abused or
graped to actually come out I agree with
you 100 yeah that's true do you guys
think that the accusers should face jail
time if they're found out to be lying
yes
yeah
winning lives yeah you have I mean if
they are innocent which you know
so far there's no evidence that I've
seen to sort of make me think that they
are
um guilty if they are innocent they've
had a large chunk of their lives taken
away from them you know what's it been
like a year now over 14 months going
through this over a year yeah then we're
saying we're looking at another two plus
years for this trial to happen you've
taken that large chunk of their lives
the way which they can't get back which
they could have been spending with their
families or you know doing things they
enjoy so that and you've put them
through some form of torture like I
think it is yeah that is literally try
to ruin their life and he's they're
living on edge all the time in fear
worried like as much as they probably
don't want to admit it they are probably
fearful of the future because they they
could be killed or in prison for
something they didn't do so it's like
yeah but that's what happens when you
challenge you know the most powerful
people on the planet yes you know I mean
not not that's not a dis against the
boys but uh yeah I mean if you if you
keep poking the bear the bear wakes up
you know slashes your face can't be like
oh what happened yeah I guess they're
sexist yeah yeah you know something
interesting I've heard that this is part
of the Matrix again that letting
anomalies because it wouldn't be as fun
for them if everything was uh flat it's
an interesting uh side of the story I
mean they are allowing uh like people
like Andrew to like come up and speak
because if they didn't want to and they
were uh just like uh super super uh
decisive about it they should have like
uh made him shut up since day one right
right right right without even giving
like space to a propaganda or like fame
or being influential make like a an
example out of him yeah you know what if
they make them smarter I mean forget it
and it's gonna be there'd be riots yeah
I'm gonna Read Super chats for a second
um z um Bastion thank you for the Super
Chat 93 tote pie um those are bad
uh there are bad men but who supports
abortion who supports Tran surgeries
like jazz just to be like to be accepted
by Society women 93 topai I'm girl in
the blue is pure beauty and smart
marry me is that me I think so yeah
you have two not one but two marriage
marriage requests for two dollars
set more money people come on I mean I
never said it'd be a good ring I just
Let me refresh it really quick
and then
let me just make sure also guys like the
video and that's the most important
metric that YouTube uses to push out
these streams but I do think we are
going to close out the show because it's
almost midnight so
um I appreciate you guys all coming on
um we're gonna do final thoughts so
anything you want to speak your piece on
you feel like you didn't get enough time
or whatever now is your time
um also you can say any social media
where people can find you I'm starting
here and then go around I finally I feel
like I've woken up for like the third
time in my in my life so not to say that
I was sleeping before but I've actually
learned a lot from everybody here today
um so yeah thanks a lot for having me on
the show
um my name is Savannah and Tony and you
can find me online as Antonia d
well thank you very much for having me
tonight Pearl uh it's a pleasure as
always actually I just want to tell the
people who are listening to us that men
and women should live together and we
rely on each other and that separation
is not the way we have to gather a
certain type of uh just uh awareness to
understand what's happening in the world
to just make our judgments based on what
we are tangibly seeing not what other
people tell us and in the final uh
aspect we're all humans and we are
allowed to make mistakes and yeah that's
it and just to be compassionate and
positive about uh I mean us as people
and if you want to follow me on my
Instagram it's yusra underscore b-e-n-s
and yeah that's it and thank you once
more
yeah thank you for having me Po
um my final thoughts are you should
never I think you've seen if you've
watched this to the end
um you would have learned that
mainstream media and the media in
general can twist anything to push a
certain view or to control the
population
um so don't readily trust the media
um because they are lying to you about
the majority of things I would say and
they're trying to push a message which
is usually the wrong one so whatever
they say A good rule that I follow
sometimes whatever they say the opposite
is usually true so go and look into the
opposite of what they're saying and then
see that there's actually more evidence
to support that
um so yeah I would say definitely in
terms of Andrew Tay innocent till proven
guilty and I stand by that in order to
protect everyone's freedom of speech and
everyone's safety
um in terms of their freedom because
that is a massive breach of Human Rights
if they do get imprisoned with no
evidence
um so yeah my Instagram and Twitter is
Nazarene Veronica so yeah if you want to
follow me you can
I would just say before you believe
anything make sure you do thorough
research don't just be a sheep don't
just blindly believe things you see out
there you can follow me on Instagram hot
dude life and you can also follow me on
my YouTube channel Modern Life dating
all one word
and that's all I gotta say
good go ahead hey guys
I forgot mine is gonna just be so short
but
um I've actually learned a lot today
and I love it I literally love it I just
feel like the conversations were really
fun to go along but yeah thank you for
having me and if you guys are from
London and want your teeth whitened
hit up smile Hub and my personal
Instagram is free underscores full stop
res
yeah
well thank you guys all for coming what
a fun panel you ever noticed how you
know pretty pretty women like the teets
you know
they're more conservative it's like
um anyways guys uh make sure you like
the video on your way out um subscribe
to the channel we're trying to get to 2
million before the end of the year so
make sure you hit the Subscribe button
also guys
sign up for our memberships a fourth
tier seriously uh one-on-one call with
me once a month I'm telling you I will
help you grow your YouTube channel if
you're new on YouTube you want to know
what to do I got 1.5 a million
subscribers in a year year and a half
um also guys subscribe to wife school if
you want to see me learn how to dance
you know bust a move I can do a mean
shimmy subscribe subscribe to wife
school like the video on your way out
seriously the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
and I'll talk to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's Village Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men now I'm
not saying you have to be submissive to
every old waste man walking around I'm
just saying that it would be femininity
would be in your nature breaking it is
to find somebody you're compatible with
that you'd like not just of your same
generation and that likes the same
things that you do going out having fun
get out okay okay then then get out then
get out after Esther then get out I'm
not here to get canceled today most men
want a woman that has some degree of
femininity where they feel like they're
taken care of taking care of I'm
ladylike I'm submissive and you'll be
surprised because I will say what I want
to say now and I'll say what I want to
say with my mind but my demeanor doesn't
change and I'm gonna look down on him
because at the end of the day whoever
you're with is a reflection of you what
has happened to society that has made
the normal man a waste man I would feel
to buy like a three thousand dollar bag
cookies
[Music]